la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
thème femme et retraite
la Conférence des Présidents a décidé
d'organiser ce débat en deux parties
dans un premier temps nous entendrons
les orateurs des groupes puis le
gouvernement nous procéderons ensuite à
une série de questions-réponses
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Mathilde panot pour 10 minutes
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre collègue
elle serait à la retraite dans 15 ans si
le gouvernement ne pondait pas une
connerie d'ici là c'était loin encore
elle comptait les jours le week-end elle
voyait sa soeur elle rendait visite à
des copines c'était fou le nombre de
femmes seules qui voulaient profiter de
la vie elle faisait des balades
s'inscrivait à des voyages organisés
dans leur vie les enfants les bonhommes
n'auraient été qu'un épisode première de
leur sorte elle s'offrait une escapade
hors des servitudes millénaires tout ce
temps les femmes avaient tenu endurante
et malmenée
l'escapade hors des servitudes
millénaires dont parle l'écrivain
Nicolas Mathieu attendra deux ans pas de
plage de galets ou de camping pour Steph
Corinne winness avec votre réforme elles
devront travailler deux années de plus
même en ayant acquis tout leur trimestre
grâce à leurs enfants
vous aviez pourtant des milliers
d'options mais c'est sur les dos des
femmes que vous voulez faire des
économies les femmes les millions de
femmes les mêmes qui ont tenu le pays
debout pendant la crise de covid-19
77% des professions de santé
94% des aides à domicile 64% des
personnels de nettoyage 67% du corps
enseignant encensé à l'époque par
Emmanuel Macron qui semblait
provisoirement retrouver le chemin de la
gratitude depuis rien n'a été fait pour
améliorer leurs conditions de travail
rien pour augmenter les rémunérations
rien pour prendre en compte la
pénibilité de leur métier pire encore la
réforme des retraites est une régression
sociale sans précédent et les femmes en
seront les premières victimes
car dans chaque angle mort dans chaque
point aveugle de votre réforme on trouve
des femmes derrière la fable des 1200
euros pour tous ces centaines de
milliers de femmes qui ne toucheront
rien faute d'être parvenu à une carrière
complète au SMIC derrière le recul de
l'âge de départ les femmes qui partent
déjà plus tard que les hommes à la
retraite à 62 ans et 7 mois en moyenne
pour elle contre 62 ans pour les hommes
20% des femmes sont obligées d'attendre
d'avoir 67 ans pour arrêter de
travailler contre 10% des hommes c'est
donc à elle que vous demandez encore des
efforts c'est d'ailleurs écrit noir sur
blanc dans votre étude d'impact les
femmes de la génération 1980 devront
travailler huit mois de plus en moyenne
contre 4 mois pour les hommes
derrière le recul de l'âge de départ
encore des femmes à qui on annule le
bénéfice des trimestres supplémentaires
à qui grâce à la maternité même les
républicains vous demandent de revoir
votre copie on se souviendra qu'en 2023
Éric Ciotti donnait des leçons de
féminisme à la macronie dans la trappe
de pauvreté toujours des femmes 45% des
nouvelles retraités étaient sans emploi
contre 35% des nouveaux retraités
combien de femmes seront coincées dans
ce sas de précarité avec votre réforme
combien d'entre elles seront au chômage
ou en invalidité peu importe pour vous
les économies d'abord les inégalités
après si on a le temps
derrière la suppression du critère
d'exposition aux agents chimiques on
trouve des coiffeuses qui respirent de
l'ammoniac plusieurs heures d'affilée ou
ses ouvrières du textile qui manipulent
des solvants à longueur de journée
derrière la non prise en compte de
certains métiers pénibles ces aides à
domicile qui portent leur passion à bout
de bras c'est que Sierre qui soulève
jusqu'à 2 tonnes de marchandises par
jour ces infirmières qui ont une
espérance de vie de 7 ans inférieure à
celle de la moyenne des femmes et qui
pour 20% d'entre elles partent à la
retraite en incapacité toutes celles qui
occupent les métiers des services c'est
subissent des cadences de plus en plus
fortes jusqu'à rêver du tic-tac de la
caisse automatique la nuit on leur
diagnostique un syndrome du canal
carpien elle finissent opérer du poignet
ou des mains elle souffre d’ernis de mal
de dos chronique elle peine à bouger les
épaules toutes ces femmes cassées par le
boulot et dont les douleurs ne sont
jamais reconnues comme des maladies
professionnelles
derrière les accidents du travail de
plus en plus de femmes les accidents
avec arrêt de travail ont augmenté de
28% pour les femmes en 15 ans quand
elles ont diminué de 28% pour les hommes
si bien qu'une aide à domicile a plus de
risques d'un accident du travail qu'un
travailleur du BTP voilà comment on
passe d'une réforme soit disant de
progrès de justice sociale à une réforme
profondément sexiste au commencement
c'est aveu terrible du ministre Esther
la réforme pénalise un peu les femmes
comme si les femmes n'étaient pas déjà
pénal pénalisés dans la société du fait
d'être des femmes pire comme s'il
s'agissait d'une anecdote dans un
inconvénient à la marge dans l'ennui
dont on peut s'accommoder cette réforme
pénalise les femmes donc la majorité de
la population et alors
que dites-vous si ce n'est après tout ce
ne sont que des femmes ce n'est pas
grave si les femmes subissent des temps
partiels sont victimes de discrimination
à l'embauche ont des salaires 22%
inférieurs à ceux des hommes et des
retraites 40% inférieures ce qu'aucun
index n'a d'ailleurs jamais permis de
réserver après tout ce ne sont que des
femmes pas grave non plus si l'écart de
patrimoine entre les femmes et les
hommes et passer en 15 ans de 9% à 16%
pas grave si les femmes
étaientrosexuelles perçoivent en moyenne
32% de moins que leur conjoint si bien
qu'elles doivent compter sur l'effet de
pension de réversion pour vivre à la
retraite et choisir ainsi à l'aube de
leur vie entre le mariage ou la pauvreté
après tout ce ne sont que des femmes pas
si grave de reconduire la division genre
et du travail avec des métiers occupés
majoritairement par des femmes moins
valorisées moins rémunérés malgré leur
utilité sociale all prétexte qu'il
serait naturel pour elle de prendre soin
des autres pas si grave que ces femmes
le pays au prix fort au moment de leur
retraite après tout ce ne sont que des
femmes
je vous entends déjà me dire cette
réforme ne peut pas résoudre les
inégalités qui précèdent la retraite
comme le disent les sociologues Céline
Bessières et Cybille golak vous
repoussez la ligne d'arrivée en faisant
mine d'ignorer que la moitié des
coureurs ont des semelles de plomb les
îles inégalités que vous ne corrigez pas
sont celles que vous perpétuez au fond
vous êtes de vrais conservateurs qui ne
souhaitent pas que la société change et
si vous voulez faire travailler les
femmes davantage c'est au mépris du
travail qu'elles accomplissent déjà tout
au long de leur vie
celle en couple avec enfant travaille en
moyenne 54 heures par semaine contre 51
heures pour les hommes dans la même
situation seulement un tiers de ce
travail rémunéré pour les femmes contre
deux tiers pour les hommes car la vie de
tant de femmes est rythmée par une
charge mentale une interminable liste de
tâches pour lesquelles nous vous en
déplaise elles n'ont aucun goût ni dont
inné pensez au coton-tiges vérifiez quel
jour la nounou part en vacances faire le
chèque pour le voyage scolaire se
libérer pour la réunion
parents-professeurs prendre un congé
quand le petit est malade l'aider dans
ses devoirs changer le billet de train
faire les courses laver à la main le
maillot de foot plein de boue recoudre
les boutons prendre rendez-vous pour le
rappel du vaccin rendre la BD à la
bibliothèque emmener les petits à la
guitare préparez le goûter faire à
manger passer l'aspirateur repasser les
affaires du petit étendre le linge vider
le lave-vaisselle
car oui les femmes passent encore
aujourd'hui deux fois plus de temps à
faire le ménage et à s'occuper des
enfants que les hommes vous n'avez aucun
égard pour ce travail invisible gratuit
épuisant ou ne vous entrainera jamais
vanter la société de l'effort ou la
valeur travail à ce sujet puisque ce
travail n'est accompli que par des
femmes voilà le vrai visage des grands
réformateurs qui affichent en vitrine
une grande cause du quinquennat tout en
préparant la réforme la plus
réactionnaire dans l'arrière boutique ce
débat est d'ailleurs l'occasion pour
certains de réveiller les pires pensifs
anti-féministe quand le rassemblement
national convoque l'imaginaire
nauséabonde de la politique nataliste
promet un discours où les femmes
seraient des utérus surpassent vous ne
mouffez pas
ils disent que le déficit imaginaire des
retraites peut être comblée par des
grossesses et il n'y en a pas un chez
vous qui élève les yeux au ciel faut-il
rappeler ici que le modèle de l'extrême
droite est celui de la Hongrie ou de la
Pologne ou l'avortement est quasi
interdit et où on fait écouter le cœur
du foetus aux femmes enceintes
lorsqu'elles décident d'avorter
ni politique nathalys ni exploitation
des femmes une bonne réforme des
retraites n'est pas celle qui prend les
femmes pour des ventres ou pour une
variable d'ajustement budgétaire vous
voulez lutter contre les inégalités
augmenter les salaires portez le SMIC à
1600 euros net dégeler le point d'indice
des fonctionnaires revaloriser les
métiers du soin et du lien
fonctionnariser les aesh et autres
métiers féminisés sanctionner
véritablement les entreprises qui ne
respectent pas l'égalité salariale
professionnelle financer un plan massif
d'éducation à l'égalité de genre créer
un service public de la petite enfance
ouvrez 500 000 places en crèches surtout
surtout supprimer la décote et faites la
retraite à 60 ans
car oui collègue une réforme juste
implique nécessairement de s'attaquer à
la longue histoire qui mène des millions
de femmes à un sort misérables lors de
leur retraite
j’achève en les saluant les aides à
domicile aide-soignante infirmière
secrétaire professeur des écoles femme
de ménage coiffeuse esthéticienne
gynécologue serveuse professionnelle de
la justice agricultrice assistante
maternelle vendeuse toutes ces femmes
sans lequel notre pays ne tiendrait pas
debout je laisse à dire et leur dit que
le combat n'est jamais vain je leur dis
rendez-vous le 7 mars pour bloquer votre
gouvernement nous allons vous faire
battre en retraite et ainsi rendre
possible l'escapade or des sévirgitudes
millénaires que les femmes méritent
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
à Monsieur Yannick noeuder pour les
républicains et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues vous le savez les
républicains sont très attachés à la
sauvegarde de notre système de retraite
par répartition garant de la solidarité
nationale telle que voulu par le général
de Gaulle à l'issue de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale toutefois si une réforme est
donc nécessaire celle-ci ne doit pas se
faire au détriment des femmes la
présidente panneau vient d'ailleurs de
rappeler les propos en ce sens du
président scioti au delà elle doit même
corriger les nombreux inégalités du
marché du travail qui se répercute
immédiatement sur les pensions de
retraite des femmes car oui s'appuyant
sur des éléments de droit créé il y a
une époque très différentes le débat
concernant la retraite des femmes est
complexe c'est là aussi notre combat
notre droite c'est la droite de la
valeur du travail qui s'est protégé les
travailleurs notre droite c'est la
droite de l'émancipation des femmes
celle qui leur a permis de voter de
travailler d'être indépendante d'avoir
accès à l'IVG grâce à Simone Veil notre
droite c'est la droite qui par ailleurs
veillera toujours à protéger derrière
hachée liée à la maternité notre droite
c'est donc la droite qui se tient au
côté des femmes qui travaillent et je
veux saluer ici tout particulièrement le
travail acharné de notre collègue
Véronique louvagi au service d'une
retraite pour toutes les femmes oui
madame la ministre Michel collègue une
trop grande injustice pèse sur la
retraite des femmes ces femmes qui
consolident le régime par répartition en
participant au renouvellement des
générations alors qu'elles ont du fait
de leur congé maternité des carrières
ralenties par rapport à celle des hommes
ces mers qui suite au recul de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans se verront annuler des
trimestres de majoration acquis au titre
de leur grossesse celle-ci pourrait
perdre le bénéfice d'un nombre de
trimestres allant jusqu'à 8 trimestres
c'est même mère qui accumulent plus ou
moins de trimestres selon si elle
travaille dans le secteur public ou le
secteur privé ou encore ses veuves qui
bénéficient ou non d'une pension de
réversion selon des critères devenus
obsolètes parmi les 4,4 millions
bénéficiaires de la reversion 88% sont
des femmes en somme les débats autour de
la refonte de notre système des
retraites a mis en lumière les
inégalités qui pèsent sur les pensions
de retraite des femmes par rapport à
celle des hommes pourtant les
républicains avaient pour ambition de
rectifier ces inégalités il nous
semblait plus important que jamais de
soutenir les familles en proposant par
exemple de baisser le taux de CSG sur le
revenu d'activité des mers ou de
rétablir l'universalité des allocations
familiales
des mesures qui auraient permis de
commencer à compenser les nombreux
rabots opérés depuis une dizaine
d'années sous les quinquennats de
François Hollande et d'Emmanuel Macron
et ayant pénalisé ces dernières années
les mères de famille qui travaillent il
aurait été aussi important de donner la
possibilité aux femmes ayant eu deux
enfants ou plus et qui ont atteint la
durée nécessaire pour obtenir le taux
plein de pouvoir partir à la retraite
plutôt mais c'était sans compter sur
l'extrême gauche qui par son obstruction
n'a pas permis de faire avancer le débat
cette gauche qui sait qui s'est bannir
qui s'est brandir pardon le féminisme
sur les plateaux télés et les réseaux
sociaux mais qui ne sait plus défendre
les femmes à l'Assemblée nationale alors
même que c'est celle c'est elle
qu'est-ce qu'elles attendent de leur
représentants mais nous ne lâcherons
rien et nous savons que les sénateurs
poursuivront notre combat au service
d'une retraite juste pour les femmes le
président Bruno Retailleau a par exemple
proposé une surcote de 5% pour les
maires de famille qui auraient atteint à
la fois une carrière complète et là je
l'égale soit un départ de 63 ans
mais Monsieur le monsieur le ministre du
socle annonçait lui-même dans la presse
qu'il était je le cite d'accord avec
nous et ouvert puisque je le cite à
nouveau on peut les trouver on peut
trouver des solutions pour améliorer le
texte quant à la situation des femmes
cette lucidité tant attendue serait-elle
toutefois un aveu d'échec dans la
continuité des déclarations de Monsieur
le Ministre Richter je vous pose la
question en tout cas reconnaître
simplement ces inégalités ne suffit pas
il faut les courir les corriger les
dépublés les députés les républicains
espérant que vous saurez mettre en
pratique vos déclarations nous
veillerons jusqu'au bout à ce que les
femmes ne soient pas la les grandes
oubliées de cette réforme la justice
sociale pour toutes et tous là et notre
compas et notre cap je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Géraldine Bannier pour le groupe
démocrate et pour cinq minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues parler retraite des
femmes c'est inévitablement se pencher
sur la question des inégalités qui bien
en amont pendant l'activité
professionnelle mais aussi dans la
société perdure et ce parachève ainsi
sans qu'on puisse être surpris au moment
de la retraite même si les choses
progressent ces fort heureusement il
faut bien faire le constat que les
femmes ont trop longtemps été un impensé
des réformes de retraite pour rappel sur
9 réformes en 50 ans ce n'est qu'à
partir de la réforme Fillon de 2003 que
ce sujet femme arrive longtemps nombre
de femmes pensons à l'agricultrice la
commerçante ont travaillé comme elle le
disait même pour leur mari sans être
déclaré ni cotisée et non eu quelque
part que leurs yeux pour pleurer en
constatant à l'heure de la retraite que
bien qu'ayant travaillé tout autant que
leur époux avec un temps consacré à
l'éducation des enfants et aux tâches
ménagères très largement majoritaires
elle ne pouvait prétendre à une pension
équivalente au seul minimum vieillesse
elles ont pourtant participé ces femmes
à la richesse du pays
de plus les femmes parce qu'elles se
retirent de l'emploi pour prendre en
charge les enfants lorsqu'elles ont du
mal à trouver un mode de garde parce que
ce sont elles aussi qui vont plutôt
interrompre leur activité vers 50 ans
pour s'occuper d'un parent malade ou
dépendant sont aussi les premières
concernées par les carrières courtes le
temps partiel des salaires inférieurs en
2022 selon les chiffres de l'INSEE les
salaires des femmes sont inférieurs en
moyenne de 22% à ceux des hommes
on arrive à se constat sans appel 37%
des femmes retraitées contre 15% des
hommes touchent moins de 1000 euros de
pension brutes le taux de pauvreté des
femmes retraitées aussi sensiblement
plus élevées 10,4 contre
8,4%. les femmes sont aussi davantage
contraintes à liquider leurs droits vers
l'âge de 65 ans et au-delà 19% de la
génération de 1950 contre 10% des hommes
pour éviter une décote
le texte de réforme en cours sans
prétendre pouvoir répondre à l'ensemble
des sujets en amont prend pour le moins
en compte le problème par plusieurs
mesures pour rappel l'âge d'annulation
la décote restera 67 ans c'était
impératif puisque ce sont d'abord les
femmes qui n'ayant pu avoir tout leur
trimestres et travaillant jusqu'à 67 ans
sont concernés par ce seuil d'annulation
la décote
le sujet des carrières incomplètes ou HS
se voit pris en compte par l'octroi
nouveau de trimestres pour congés
parental jusqu'à 4 dans dispositif
carrière longue 2000 femmes seront
concernées chaque année la prise en
compte des trimestres cotisés
d'assurance vieillesse pour parents au
foyer avpf jusqu'à 4 est aussi une
avancée ce sont plus souvent les femmes
que les hommes qui remplissent ce rôle
des dents et selon gouvernement cela
permettra à 2% de femmes supplémentaires
d'avoir accès aux myco majoré qui
nécessite pour rappel 120 trimestres
cotisés
les femmes seront aussi plus nombreuses
29% contre 17% des hommes à pouvoir
bénéficier du dispositif pour les
petites pensions à savoir l'augmentation
du minimum contributif la réforme
prévoit en effet l'augmentation du socle
de base du minimum contributif à hauteur
de 25 euros et sa majoration de 75 euros
les femmes bénéficieraient d'une hausse
plus franche en moyenne 38 euros bruts
par mois contre 25 euros brut pour les
hommes
enfin sur le sujet de trois trimestres
pour enfants 4 trimestres dans le privé
dedans le public mesure instaurer la fin
des années 60 pour compenser la perte de
trimestre liée à la grossesse quand
souvent elles arrêtaient de travailler
il est utile de rappeler que le
dispositif se poursuit avec toujours la
possibilité de transférer quatre
trimestres complémentaires octroyés pour
l'éducation à l'autre parent
l'amendement déposée par notre groupe
démocrates et visant à ce que les femmes
ayant eu des enfants avant 2012 puissent
intégrer leurs indemnités de congé
maternité dans le calcul de leur pension
est repris par le gouvernement la loi
prévoyait cette possibilité pour les
congés maternités pris à partir du 1er
janvier 2012 mais pas avant c'est donc
une avancée complémentaire et attendue
le débat n'ayant pas pu se dérouler
comme nous l’aurions souhaité le sujet
de la pénibilité naguère était contrevue
c'est un vrai regret car trop souvent
celle des métiers féminins et comme
cultés invisibilisé on peut le
comprendre quand les représentations
mentales sont liées aux images de port
de charge lourdes à celle du
marteau-piqueur de la truelle ou du
bitume sur les chantiers il y a pourtant
des métiers exercés majoritairement par
des femmes extrêmement pénibles
compensent notamment aux
aides-soignantes qui soulève les
patients par exemple les femmes sont
pour rappel beaucoup plus concernés par
les troubles musculo-squelettiques elles
devront faire l'objet d'une attention
toute particulière du nouveau plan de
prévention doté d'un milliard d'euros
qui sera mis en place
l'abaissement des seuils pour le travail
de nuit dans le cadre du C2P s'ennuie au
lieu de 120 et le travail en équipe
successive 30 au lieu de 50 le
déplafonnement des 100 points le
renforcement de la valeur des points
pour l'accès à la formation ou au temps
partiel la mise en place également du
suivi médical personnalisé sont des
points importants particulièrement pour
les femmes
ainsi si le débat actuel appelle
évidemment à poursuivre la voie ouverte
pour réduire les inégalités salariales
entre hommes et femmes première cause
des inégalités au moment de la retraite
c'est plus largement une réforme massive
des représentations des pratiques que
chacun d'entre nous citoyens élus chefs
d'entreprise homme ou femme est appelé
collègue pour qu'un jour on ne soit plus
obligé d'organiser ce type de débat
l'assemblée strictement réservé aux
femmes merci
madame la députée et la parole est à
Monsieur Bertrand petit pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté et pour 5
minutes
merci madame la Présidente de ma
présidente la main ministre chers
collègues il y a dix jours le
gouvernement à clos prématurément les
débats sur le projet de loi de réforme
des retraites sans laisser la
possibilité aux députés de débattre des
mesures d'âge lesquels sont porteuses
d'injustice profondes pour les Français
et les Françaises
en particulier les femmes porteront
l'essentiel du poids de la réforme elle
représente le profil des perdantes
annoncées à rebours des contre-vérités
du gouvernement ainsi l'économiste
Michael Zemmour a estimé qu'environ 60%
des économies recherchées par la réforme
d'ici 2030 soit 17,7 milliards d'euros
par an pesé sur les femmes ce chiffre
non infirmé par la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale lors du contrôle sur
pièce et sur place de mon collègue
Jérôme Guedj vice-président de la mecs
et tout simplement inadmissible
il est encore davantage quand on se
remémore que des injustices pèsent
d'ores et déjà sur les femmes tout au
long de leur carrière il est encore
davantage quand on se remémore que des
injustices pèsent d'ores et déjà sur les
femmes tout au long de leur carrière
tout d'abord les critères des carrières
courtes pardon concernent davantage les
femmes que les hommes quand les femmes
accouchent elles basculent souvent et
nous le savons sur du temps partiel ou
se retire temporairement de la vie
professionnelle pour se consacrer à
l'éducation de leur enfant mécaniquement
les femmes sont plus nombreuses à
attendre l'âge d'annulation de la décote
pour partir liquider leurs droits 19%
des femmes contre 10% des hommes les
carrières fractionnées concernent
également davantage les femmes elles
sont également plus nombreuses à
renoncer à leur carrière pour assister
un proche en perte d'autonomie les
femmes plus touchées par les carrières
courtes sont ainsi perdantes face à la
réforme des retraites qui exigent une
carrière complète de 43 trois ans à
temps plein pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein le même constat
s'impose concernant la retraite à 1200
euros dont Jérôme Guedj a démontré lors
de nos débats la faiblesse du nombre de
bénéficiaires le ministre Olivier du
soft a ainsi indiqué hier par courrier
contre Jimmy et vingt mille personnes
par an en bénéficierait le gouvernement
n'a pas donné la répartition homme-femme
de ce bénéfice dans son courrier d'hier
nous attendons donc cette précision même
si le choix du gouvernement d'augmenter
le minimum contributifs majoré des 75
euros et le minimum contributif de 25
euros va par nature désavantager les
femmes qui ont généralement moins de
trimestres cotisés que les hommes or le
minimum contributif majoré exige des
trimestres cotisés et non validés la
conséquence de votre réforme apparaît
clairement les femmes sont amenées à
travailler plus longtemps pour
bénéficier d'une requête d'une retraite
à taux plein au niveau actuel
le gouvernement lui-même reconnu dans
son étude d'impact les femmes de la
génération 1970 vont en moyenne partir
en retraite à 63,50 avant réforme et
64,50 par après réformes soit 12 mois
supplémentaires tandis que les hommes de
cette même génération vont en moyenne
partie en retraite à 64 ans avant
réforme et à 64 ans et 7 mois après
réformes soit 8 mois et demi
supplémentaires enfin la justice majeure
que constitue l'importante inégalité de
revenus et de pension entre les femmes
et les hommes n'est aucunement prise en
compte dans votre réforme mes risques
d'être accentués avec le recul de l'âge
de la retraite comme un allongement de
la durée de cotisation sur ce sur ce
dernier point votre étude d'impact n'a
pas évalué les pertes sur les pensions
de retraite des femmes liées à
l'annulation liée au décalage de l'âge
légal de 64 de 62 à 64 ans le surcote
dont pouvait bénéficier les femmes qui
travaillaient au delà de cet âge légal
pour mesurer ses effets entre catégories
professionnelles et disposées d'un débat
éclairé nous avons demandé au
gouvernement plus d'informations et plus
de temps
à cette guerre le double refus du
gouvernement est inacceptable si on
comprend que les femmes seront en
moyenne plus concernées que les hommes
par le décalage de l'âge de la retraite
nous n'avons pas les détails de ces
effets selon les profils hormis des
moyennes dans les hypothèses sont
beaucoup trop générales nulle part nous
ne disposons d'indications claires sur
les effets de la réforme du dispositif
carrière longue sur les femmes qui en
bénéficient en proportion moins que les
hommes pas de transparence non plus
concernant le nombre de femmes qui pour
la réforme annulera le bénéfice des
majorations de trimestres enfin le corps
note que le taux de pauvreté des
retraités augmente depuis 2016 en
particulier pour les personnes
âgées de plus de 65 ans qui vivent seuls
parmi elles ce toit un même 16,5% pour
les femmes quelle va être l'impact de la
réforme sur ce taux de pauvreté des
femmes vous ne le précisez pas les
français ne s'y sont pas trompés et
rejettent massivement la régression sans
débat suffisamment long et éclairé que
souhaite imposer le gouvernement nous
vous demandons des précisions détaillées
sur l'ensemble de ces points
merci
madame Anne-Cécile violent pour le
groupe horizon et à parenté et pour 5
minutes
merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues
je me réjouis de pouvoir nourrir
aujourd'hui le débat entamé il y a
quelques semaines sur les retraites et
de fait dans de bien meilleures
conditions cette fois-ci
je souhaite en effet rappeler mon
profond regret et désaccord avec la
façon dont les débats ce sont déroulés
nous empêchant des échanges constructifs
nos concitoyens ne méritent pas ces
mises en scène et ses campagnes de
désinformation et en l'occurrence la
cause des femmes a été tellement
instrumentaliste je vous invite à
écouter l'oratrice qui est le seul à la
parole merci en l'occurrence la cause
des femmes a été tellement
instrumentalisée alors qu'elle mérite
tellement plus de décence et de dignité
nous avons eu l'occasion au sein de la
délégation des droits aux femmes
d'aborder la question des femmes dans
cette réforme de retraite
dans un climat apaisé constructif sans
doute car loin des caméras pour autant
je remercie le groupe et les filles de
l'avoir inscrit à l'ordre du jour et de
permettre des échanges au-delà des
postures et des caricatures c'est une
question primordiale qui mérite
l'attention de tous et le respect de
chacun
permettez-moi de développer quelques
chiffres les femmes liquides leurs
droits à la retraite en moyenne 10 mois
après les hommes en 2021
en moyenne les retraités perçoivent 1459
euros par mois les hommes reçoivent en
moyenne 1674 euros et les femmes n'en
perçoivent en moyenne que
1272 soit 24% de moins que les hommes et
si nous déduisons la majoration de
pensions perçues pour trois enfants ou
plus cet écart de pension de retraite
perçue entre les hommes et les femmes
s'élèvent à 39% les femmes perçoivent en
moyenne une retraite inférieure de 39% à
celle des hommes
cette réforme a donc été l'occasion de
rappeler que la situation des femmes est
particulièrement inégalitaire face aux
pensions de retraite
certaines de ces inégalités peuvent être
corrigées par une réforme des retraites
c'est par exemple la prise en compte des
situations d'interruption d'activité des
femmes en prenant en compte des
trimestres d'interruption à la fois pour
la durée retenue pour l'éligibilité aux
carrières longues et pour celle retenue
pour l'attribution de la retraite
minimale qui sera en outre valorisée de
même il est important de noter que la
revalorisation des petites pensions
favorisera majoritairement les femmes
puisque près de 30% d'entre elles
verront leur pension augmentée je ne
n'oublie pas que cette augmentation est
avant tout la conséquence des faibles
pensions perçues par les femmes
évidemment toutes ces inégalités
existent depuis trop longtemps sans
doute une réforme systémique aurait
permis d'aller plus vite et plus loin
dans la correction de ces injustices
pour cette raison je veux rappeler que
la meilleure manière de lutter contre
ces inégalités et d'abord et avant tout
de s'attaquer à l'inégalité
professionnelle aux différents
salariales à la question des métiers
pénibles les écarts de pension
s'expliquent en grande partie par ces
écarts de salaire contre lesquels il
faut absolument lutter le système de
retraite évidemment ne peut
intégralement le corriger quand
considérerons nous enfin la femme comme
un homme comme les autres mais je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Madame Soumia
bouroua pour le groupe gauche
démocratique annulé mais pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
chers collègue cela fait maintenant
plusieurs semaines que le gouvernement
et la majorité travaillent ces éléments
de langage pour tenter de nous faire
croire que sa réforme des retraites
serait juste équilibrée les femmes
seraient même les premières gagnantes
alors que même le ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement dit le
contraire le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui en hémicycle et donc
l'occasion de rappeler quelques faits et
d'expliquer pourquoi cette réforme n'est
favorable en aucun de nos pour aucun de
nos concitoyens et certainement pas aux
femmes premièrement cette réforme va
davantage les impacter car elles vont
être davantage touchées par le
relèvement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et voici quelques exemples
parlants
pour la génération des femmes qui sont
nées à partir de 1966 l'âge de départ
légal moyen et repoussé de 7 mois pour
les femmes contre 5 mois pour les hommes
pour la génération qui sont nés à partir
de 1972 c'est encore pire en effet l'âge
de départ légale moyen recule de 9 mois
pour les femmes contre 5 mois pour les
hommes par ailleurs l'accélération
brutale de la réforme Touraine affaiblit
la portée de l'avantage des trimestres à
qui par enfant ce phénomène est
parfaitement prévisible mais le
gouvernement a fait le choix de ne pas
augmenter ce bénéfice
proportionnellement au rallongement de
la durée de travail
il faut également signaler que si dans
le privé ce bénéfice pour les femmes est
de 8 trimestres par enfant dans le
public c'est seulement deux trimestres
par enfant s'ils sont nés après 2004 et
4 trimestres si son nez avant 2004
si ce projet de réforme avait été
cohérent vis-à-vis de l'objectif affiché
au projet avantageux pour les femmes
nous aurions pu penser que cette
inégalité aurait fait l'objet d'un geste
par le gouvernement mais rien les
avantages de cette réforme ne
s'adressent en réalité qu'aux capital et
aux actionnaires
en ce qui concerne les cartes des
pensions entre les femmes et les hommes
il est en moyenne de 40%. ce chiffre est
largement connu il est alarmant et si le
sort des femmes préoccupait sérieusement
notre gouvernement cette question
devrait être prioritaire au sein de nos
débats malheureusement
cette réforme ne prévoit aucun
rattrapage aucune compensation si ce
n'est certainement par la petite
revalorisation du micro pour une
carrière complète au SMIC qui augmentera
la pension des femmes elles qui sont les
premières soumises au bas salaire et au
temps partiel en réalité s'il était
question d'agir concrètement pour
davantage d'égalité et de justice
sociale nous aurions eu ici un débat sur
les moyens de mettre en œuvre l'égalité
professionnelle pour permettre aux
femmes à post et compétences égales aux
hommes d'avoir la même rémunération et
donc par ricochet de toucher des
pensions de retraite qui ne soient plus
40% inférieur à celle des hommes
de plus lorsque le gouvernement nous
explique que la pension moyenne des
femmes va augmenter et qu'il s'en
réjouit il oublie de préciser que c'est
uniquement grâce à l'effort que les
femmes devront fournir en travaillant
deux années de plus
surtout le gouvernement ne parle pas de
toutes celles bien plus nombreuses qui
auront des retraites rabotées parce
qu'elles ne tiendront pas deux ans de
plus au travail parce que ce projet de
loi fait aussi l'impasse sur la
pénibilité au travail et sa compensation
or parmi les métiers à dominance
féminine je suis torer les métiers du
soin et du lien ce sont des métiers
primordiaux dans notre société mais
dévaloriser aux conditions très
précaires et pour lesquelles l'hiver
dernier la Cour des comptes à alerté sur
le taux de sinistralité hors norme ces
femmes qui travaillent dans ces métiers
du soin et du lien seront parmi les très
grandes perdants de votre réforme quant
à la prise en compte des périodes de
congé parental dans le trimestre acquis
à titre des carrières longues il s'agit
d'une avancée minuscule au regard des
réalités des besoins concrètement il
s'agira de prendre en compte quatre
trimestres pour les femmes et ayant
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans et
selon l'étude d'impact ce dispositif
concernerait 2000 ou 3000 femmes sur 400
000 qui partent en retraite chaque année
ainsi au lieu d'infliger brutalement
deux années de travail supplémentaires
aux hommes et aux femmes de ce pays il y
avait bien d'autres dispositions à
prendre des dispositions urgentes et de
progrès social il y avait aussi et
toujours la possibilité si votre
gouvernement n'a la volonté politique de
faire le choix du progrès de la justice
sociale en renonçant à cette funeste
réforme des retraites pour à la place
construire des droits collectifs plus
protecteurs et plus juste pour toute et
tous je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Madame Estelle Youssoupha pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues par les femmes
et retraites c'est parler d'inégalités
d'inégalités des sexes face à l'argent
car il me semble que l'égalité est plus
que tout une question économique et je
pense que l'hexagone serait bien inspiré
de réfléchir aux traditions de mon
département Mayotte terre française et
majoritairement musulmane Mayotte est un
matriarcat matrilinéaire les femmes y
sont chef de famille et la coutume veut
qu'a leur naissance le père construise
pour chacune de ses filles sa maison nos
coutumes mahoraises protègent les femmes
en leur garantissant un toit dans lequel
les poux n'est qu'un invité en effet à
son mariage le mahoret va habiter chez
sa femme et les enfants du couple
resteront chez leur mère Mayotte donne
ainsi le pouvoir aux femmes avec la
possession de leur foyer socle de
l'autonomie économique et cela nourrit
notre société matriarcale avec une
réelle égalité homme-femme
vous voyez aujourd'hui à Mayotte terre
française et majoritairement musulmane
un entrepreneuriat féminin extrêmement
dynamique et pilier de notre économie
notre histoire est marquée par ses
maîtresses femmes qui ont mené le combat
pour Mayotte françaises dans les années
70 je pense à Zakia Mahdi zenam déree
dont je porte les couleurs Zena meres
musula Mama Bolé Latifa tavacolo coco
Laza et toutes les autres qui ont lutté
contre les indépendantistes en chaque
touillant jusqu'au larmes les Comoriens
et autres émissaires qui voulaient
sortir Mayotte de la République
modeste mais déterminé non violente mais
en lutte les chatouillesuses ont humilié
et pourchasser les ministres et leurs
idées néfastes pour garantir un Mayotte
la liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
Mayotte la France sont l'héritière de ce
féminisme combattant la République doit
au soroda et à ses femmes de pouvoir
encore faire flotter aujourd'hui notre
drapeau tricolore sur l'île au parfum
certaines de ces femmes puissantes sont
encore parmi nous aujourd'hui et elles
vivent souvent dans le plus grand
dénuement car vous le savez les
retraites à Mayotte atteignent
péniblement 286 euros en moyenne et nos
aînés réclament de pouvoir vieillir
dignement
à travailler égal s'il y a un sexe
faible c'est surtout qu'il est
faiblement payé si l'égalité homme-femme
est toujours une grande cause nationale
force de constater que le gouvernement a
discriminer nos citoyennes dans cette
réforme de retraite force et de
constater que le gouvernement a perpétué
l'injustice économique qui frappe les
Françaises en alimentant les inégalités
dans le grand âge à titre d'exemple la
majorité de durée d'assurance pour
enfants et variable dans le privé elle
est de 8 trimestres par enfant dans le
public seulement deux trimestres par
enfant
idem pour la majorité de pensions dans
le privé elle de 10% à partir du
troisième enfant tandis que dans le
public la majoration diminue à 5% à
partir du troisième on s'y perd ne
parlons pas des pensions de réversion on
peut compter 11 régimes différents et
c'est pourtant un outil important pour
réduire les inégalités de pension entre
les hommes et les femmes car les
pensions de réversion réduisent les
quarts de 40 à 28%
le groupe liote a proposé de relever le
plafond de ressources des bénéficiaires
des pensions de réversion à 30000 euros
contre 23000 aujourd'hui nous proposons
aussi d'ouvrir les droits pour enfants
dès le deuxième enfant pour tenir compte
de la baisse du nombre d'enfants par
femme et la question n'est pas d'inciter
les françaises à avoir des enfants pour
en faire des variables d'ajustement de
notre système de retraite par
répartition non la maternité doit rester
un choix libre de toute pénalisation
professionnelle et financière il s'agit
de garantir de bonnes conditions
d'emploi et de conciliation de la vie
professionnelle pour celles qui
souhaitent fonder une famille et
d'améliorer leurs droits au moment de la
retraite la justice sociale passe par
l'égalité des sexes et l'émancipation
économique des femmes la réforme des
retraites doit revoir sa copie pour que
nos concitoyennes nos électrices ne
soient pas que de bonnes poires et que
notre système soit à la hauteur de
Marianne symbole de notre République je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Véronique Riotton
pour le gros Renaissance et pour 5
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues je prends la parole ici
au nom du groupe Renaissance sur ce
débat très opportuniments inscrits par
nos collègues de la France insoumise une
belle manière de ramener un débat quand
ils ont largement privé les Français ces
15 derniers jours il est toujours
savoureux de voir qu'il préfère le débat
maintenant alors qu'il préférait le
désordre et le chaos il y a quelques
jours il existe effectivement des
différences structurelles des inégalités
de pension entre les femmes et les
hommes et nous devons justement
impérativement identifier les racines et
les causes de ces inégalités liées
notamment une organisation du travail
qui malmène les femmes et qui se
répercutent voir ce densifie à la
retraite c'est pour cela que nous avons
d'ores et déjà fait avancer plusieurs
chantiers importants en revalorisant les
petites pensions les femmes étant plus
nombreuses à voir cotisées avec des
revenus plus modestes 33% des femmes à
la retraite obtiendront
une augmentation de leur pension sur les
2 millions de retraités actuels 60% des
femmes verront leurs pensions
revalorisées de 6,7% en moyenne contre
5,1% pour les hommes nous avons
également acté la prise en compte pour
le calcul des droits les trimestres pour
le congé parental et nous avons intégré
ces parcours dans le dispositif carrière
longue pour obtenir une retraite à taux
plein plus tôt si la France insoumise
n'avait pas de préenti et dévoyé le
débat nous aurions pu défendre cet
apport parlementaire pour acter dans la
loi une trajectoire de réduction des
inégalités à horizon d'une génération au
plus tard en 2050 les écarts de pension
entre les femmes et les hommes seront
éradiqués les travaux menés par la
présidente de la délégation au droit des
femmes nous ont permis de déterminer des
mesures structurelles pour corriger ces
inégalités nous allons travailler
concrètement à leur mise en œuvre dans
le projet de la loi
je ne parle pas ici de mesures
compensatrices de mesurettes qui
pourraient compenser un court temps ces
inégalités mais bien d'une
transformation en profondeur du travail
afin de lui redonner sa fonction
première émancipatrice c'est l'un des
principaux piliers pour atteindre
l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et les
hommes je le répète ces inégalités sont
un tolérables et contraire à notre
esprit de justice et d'équité plus
largement je considère que ces
inégalités sont un symptôme d'un mal
plus vaste celui des inégalités portant
sur la valeur travail et c'est sur cela
que nous verrons chers collègues à
l'extrême droite ou à l'extrême gauche
de cette hémicycle pour nous le travail
c'est l'émancipation la mobilité
l'agilité c'est par le travail que nous
faisons société que nous nous
nourrissons notre solidarité les
Françaises et les Français connaissent
cette valeur et l'estime ce que nous
souhaitons faire c'est valoriser le
travail autant qu'il le mérite je
souhaite que une femme puisse elles
aussi se saisir de la porter
émancipatrice du travail qu'elles
arrivent à la fin de leur carrière avec
les mêmes montants de pension que les
hommes parce qu'elles auront eu les
mêmes conditions de travail que les
hommes aujourd'hui les résultats
édifiantes ces écarts c'est la
conséquence directe des inégalités
structurelles sur le marché du travail
relative à l'emploi des femmes je
distingue trois leviers d'action au
travers que nous pourrons travailler en
tout cas lors des prochains textes
premièrement les femmes ont une
rémunération inférieure à celle des
hommes nous avons déjà travaillé sur ce
point avec la mise en place de l'index
égalité sur laquelle nous poursuivons le
travail deuxièmement les femmes occupent
plus souvent que les hommes des
positions sociaux professionnelles moins
favorables dans des secteurs d'activités
qui sont moins rémunérateurs c'est le
résultat de stéréotypes de genre et nous
devons agir sur la mixité des filières
et des métiers
aux jeunes filles de s'orienter vers des
secteurs d'avenir stratégiques comme le
numérique ou les sciences et accompagner
les entreprises à ouvrir leurs portes
aux femmes qui seraient orientent au
cours de leur carrière aujourd'hui même
messieurs dames dans cette émission le
nous recevons avec la DDF 80 lycéens qui
travaillent actuellement sur ces sujets
et dont nous aurons les résultats à 16h
c'est une invitation enfin les femmes
ont un taux d'activités inférieure à
celui des hommes elle travaille plus
souvent un temps partiel elles
interromps plus souvent leur carrière
que les hommes pour des choix familiaux
agir sur l'accès au travail et l'un des
premiers leviers pour accompagner les
femmes à l'emploi
cessons d'instrumentalisés
politiquesment ces situations et
apportons des changements structurels
des corrections des inégalités à la
racine qui seront engagés dans le
prochain texte sur le plein emploi vous
venez d'entendre quelques-unes de mes
propositions j'aimerais entendre les
vôtres maintenant plutôt que le brouhaha
auquel vous nous avez habitué messieurs
dames notre horizon c'est zéro écart à
2050 c'est l'horizon d'une génération
nous activerons tous les leviers pour
réduire et supprimer définitivement ces
écarts de pension c'est un combat
sociétal fort c'est une sorte de la
grande cause du quinquennat que nous
portons depuis 2017 je vous remercie
merci madame la députée
ma parole est à Madame Anaïs Sabatini
pour le groupe rassemblement national et
pour 5 minutes
madame la merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre chère collègues ce
débat est l'occasion de rappeler le
caractère particulièrement discriminant
pour les femmes que comporte cette
réforme des retraites et que le
gouvernement sentait pourtant imposé en
effet des à présent l'une des inégalités
homme-femme les plus criantes et celles
concernant leur situation face à la
retraite d'après l'Insee la pension
moyenne perçue par les femmes est
inférieure de près de 40% à celle des
hommes l'autoritarisme et la brutalité
du gouvernement ont encore une fois
œuvré en limitant nos débats sans parler
évidemment de l'obstruction
parlementaire absurde d'une partie de la
nupes qui en essayant de jouer les gens
moulins n'ont fait que prouver une
nouvelle fois qui ne sont que des
tartuffes tous ces comportements n'ont
eu comme incidences que de priver la
représentation nationale d'un débat d'un
débat serein sur le fond du texte
ainsi et profitons de ce débat pour
appeler qu'à l'inutilité budgétaire
s'ajoute la profonde injustice sociale
et la grande brutalité de cette réforme
qui va pénaliser les femmes en général
et à fortiori les femmes mères de
famille ou ayant une carrière hachée
dans un instant de vérité monsieur le
ministre Riester a concédé aux médias à
propos de cette réforme je cite les
femmes sont évidemment un peu pénalisées
avant d'ajouter on en discute qu'on
vient absolument pas c'est à eux qu'elle
mérite de la clarté et de l'honnêteté et
confirmée par l'étude d'impact la
réforme aura pour conséquence de reculer
de plusieurs mois là j'effectivement
moyen de départ à la retraite pour les
femmes aujourd'hui les femmes parlent
déjà plus tard à la retraite et touchent
des pensions plus faibles elles seront
ainsi davantage impactées par le report
de l'âge de la retraite toutes les
réformes qui repoussent l'âge de départ
on pourrait fait mécanique de pénaliser
les femmes plus nombreuses à avoir des
carrières hachées actuellement 40%
d'entre elles partent à la retraite avec
une carrière incomplète cette réforme
unique aura pour conséquence d'accentuer
cette injustice
dans le régime général des retraites 8
trimestres sont attribués en cas de
naissance d'un enfant quatre leçons à la
mer au titre de la naissance ou de
l'adoption or ces trimestres ne comptent
pas pour la durée de cotisations une
femme qui a validé l'ensemble de ces
trimestre avant l'âge légal devra donc
continuer à travailler le décalage de
l'âge légal de départ a donc pour
conséquence d'effacer le bénéfice des
trimestres validés pour la maternité
ainsi qu'à madame la Première ministre
déclare que les femmes partiront à la
retraite plutôt que les hommes il s'agit
une nouvelle fois de mensonge parce que
si les femmes partent actuellement plus
tard que les hommes avec votre effort
elle ne partiront sûrement pas plutôt
quant au maire de famille qui subissent
déjà l'injustice du système actuel ces
dernières se verront encore plus lésées
quelle hérésie lorsqu'on sait que ce
sont ces mêmes femmes qui sont les
pierres angulaires de notre système de
retraite par répartition puisque par
définition ce sont les enfants
d'aujourd'hui qui seront les cotisants
de demain
ce que vous proposez aux femmes est donc
la double peine elle subissent déjà une
des côtes du fait des carrières hachées
et avec votre réforme elles seront
encore plus pénalisée une campagne
familiale et nataliste aurait dû
accompagner toute réforme des retraites
sérieuses et ambitieuses encore une fois
rien n'a été anticipé par le
gouvernement contrairement à notre
président de groupe Marine Le Pen qui
est propose depuis fort longtemps des
mesures simples juste et efficaces pour
protéger les femmes plus vous avez
travaillé tôt plus vous partez tôt notre
projet est un projet de justice il
permet aux femmes à toutes les femmes y
compris les mères de famille de profiter
de leur retraite en bonne santé sans
avoir les bras cassés et le dos brisé
dans les faits ce sont les femmes qui
sont le plus fréquemment exposées aux
facteurs de risque psychosociaux ou
touchés par des maladies
professionnelles mais là encore du côté
du gouvernement rien n'a été fait pour
tenir compte de cette pénibilité à
laquelle sont confrontées les femmes au
travail de toute évidence votre réforme
aura pour conséquence de fragiliser
encore un peu plus la situation
financière de nombreuses femmes qui
exercent des métiers difficiles et que
nous pourrons pas se maintenir dans
l'emploi jusqu'à l'âge légal du départ à
la retraite la politique est avant tout
une question de choix ce gouvernement en
a fait un celui de pénaliser les femmes
en présentant une réforme qui en plus
d'être totalement injustifié est aussi
brutal qu'un juste je vous remercie
merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame
marie-charlotte-garin pour le groupe
écologiste et pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues 1145 euros par mois c'est la
pension moyenne de retraite en France
pour les femmes contre 1924 euros pour
les hommes
10,4% c'est le taux de pauvreté des
femmes retraitées il est sensiblement
plus élevé que celui des hommes et cet
écart a tendance à se creuser depuis
2012 enfin les femmes partent un peu
plus tard à la retraite que les hommes
je crois que vous voyez où je vais en
venir les inégalités de retraite sont le
miroir des inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes tout au long de la vie et
très souvent un miroir grossissant que
proposez-vous pour remédier à ces
inégalités remédier par exemple aux
inégalités professionnelles rien la loi
de 2006 n'est toujours pas appliquée et
aucune sanction en vue pour les
entreprises qui ne la respectent pas le
taux d'emploi des femmes rien la France
est 25e sur 38 pour les pays de l'OCDE
en la matière nous avons par exemple
proposé de sanctionner les employeurs
qui abuseraient des temps partiels sur
les derniers textes toujours rien ces
monnaies courantes dans certains
secteurs et en particulier dans les
secteurs fortement féminisés
si l'an dernier le taux d'activité des
femmes avait été au même niveau que
celui des hommes cela aurait été 10
milliards de cotisations supplémentaires
pour nos retraites j'insiste là-dessus
nous avons donc un manque à gagner de 10
milliards de cotisations supplémentaires
parce que les femmes travaillent moins
que les hommes et parce que les femmes
gagnent moins que les hommes pour les
inégalités salariales ça fait 5,5
milliards alors forcément là on se dit
qu'on doit pouvoir faire plus parce
qu'on arrive à un total de 15,5
milliards donc si vous vous êtes un
petit peu matheux vous comprenez que le
compteiller quand on les met en
comparaison dans la balance avec les 12
milliards de déficits temporaires et
prévisionnel annoncé par le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites et ça montre
bien finalement la priorité politique du
gouvernement qui est de faire travailler
les gens plus longtemps faire des
économies sur le dos des plus précaires
plutôt que de faire de l'égalité famome
au travail une priorité
et pour l'égalité femme homme vous ne
vous contentez pas de ne rien faire
puisque votre réforme elle va creuser
les inégalités dans un système qui est
déjà défavorable aux femmes le décalage
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
de 62 à 64 ans et surtout sur
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
vont aller vidange toucher tout le monde
mais cette décision elle va surtout
toucher tous ceux et en fait sur tout
toutes celles qui ont eu des carrières
courtes des carrières hachées et des
temps partiels alors pour bien me faire
comprendre je vous propose de prendre un
exemple nous avons Quentin et Oriane qui
sont nés en 1975 ils ont commencé à
travailler dans le privé à 23 ans ils
ont une carrière identique et ont eu
deux enfants dans le système actuel
Quentin doit attendre 66 ans pour
pouvoir partir à taux plein Oriane du
fait des trimestres gagnées en
compensation de ces deux grossesses peut
partir à 62 ans puisque c'est l'âge
légal
avec votre réforme la situation de
Quentin ne changera pas en revanche
Oriane va perdre les deux années gagnées
en compensation de ces deux grossesses
et elle va devoir travailler deux ans de
plus pour atteindre l'âge légal que vous
souhaitez à 64 ans c'est aussi simple
que cela et nous nous y opposons
allez-vous enfin reconnaître également
la pénibilité des métiers fortement
féminisés et là on parle bien évidemment
de toutes ces femmes qui ont fait
marcher le pays pendant la crise covid
nos caissières nous soignantes les
critères de pénibilité à l'heure
actuelle sont calqués sur des métiers
masculins les métiers féminisés peuvent
être tout aussi difficiles puisque les
femmes cumulent bien souvent des
contraintes physiques auxquelles il faut
ajouter des contraintes émotionnelles
qui sont très importantes et j'ajoute
aussi que les accidents du travail
progressent chez les femmes alors qu'il
baisse chez les hommes et c'est la même
chose pour les maladies professionnelles
et les troubles musculo-squelettiques
et j'ai envie de terminer on vous
partageant un témoignage de Sarah qui
infirmière à Lyon et qui nous a écrit
suite au débat qu'elle a pu voir dans
l'hémicycle
elle nous dit j'ai bossé pendant 6 ans
en réanimation des grands brûlés à
Edouard Herriot 6 ans où je me suis
brisé le dos les pansements duraient en
moyenne 1h30 par patient chaque jour les
patients prenaient en moyenne 20 kilos
de dames en fassignal on devait porter
chacun de leurs membres pour faire leur
pansements pour la plupart les personnes
étaient intubées ventilées séparés donc
elles étaient des poids morts
des patients qui pèsent rarement 50 kg
au départ donc il faut tourner porter la
jambe le bras d'un patient de 100 kg et
ce sans aide mécanique j'aimerais
vraiment avoir leur avis de comment
physiquement on peut ou doit tenir
jusqu'à 64 ans leur avis c'est votre
avis à vous le gouvernement vous avez
tenté de nous vendre une réforme juste
pour les femmes personne n'est dupe nous
soutenons les femmes et nous demandons
le retrait de cette réforme
merci madame la députée la parole est à
madame Carole Grandjean ministre délégué
chargé de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés vous proposez au
débat une question fondamentale celle de
la retraite des femmes
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
regrette de ne pas pouvoir y participer
étant retenu au même moment au Sénat les
concertations ont à cet égard étaient
très utiles et ont permis de rester
attentif aux effets pour les femmes de
chacune des dispositions de la réforme
la retraite des femmes est également au
coeur de l'examen parlementaire depuis
qu'il a commencé de fait certains
d'entre vous s'en rappelle le ministre
avait déjà eu l'occasion il y a un mois
exactement d'intervenir devant la
représentation nationale en répondant
aux questions de la délégation au droit
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes de votre
assemblée
cette audition elle a permis d'enrichir
le texte puisque le gouvernement a
soutenu est repris des amendements
issus de ces échanges ils n'ont pu
évidemment être débattus du fait du
blocage des discussions que vous avez
été ici nombreux à regretter
l'amendement déposé par la députée
Véronique Riotton vise à étendre d'ici à
2050 un objectif d'égalité des pensions
entre les hommes et les femmes d'autres
avancées c'est très précises en matière
de droit à retraite pour les parents
confrontés à la perte d'un enfant d'un
jeune enfant peuvent également être
soulignés je pense à l'amendement de la
députée Karine Lebon qui a mis en
lumière qu'actuellement dans la fonction
publique la majoration de 10% pour
famille nombreuse et perdue lorsque l'on
perd un enfant de moins de 9 ans cette
réalité doit changer
le député Paul Christophe a déposé quant
à lui un amendement afin de mettre fin à
la diminution du nombre de trimestres en
cas de décès de l'enfant avant 4 ans
d'autres amendements ont été déposés
dans cette assemblée pour remettre à
plat plus largement les droits familiaux
tels l'amendement du député Thibault
Bazin notamment et ce destiné à corriger
une inégalité qui empêche aujourd'hui
les professions libérales de bénéficier
d'une majoration de leur pension
nos débats en première lecture n'ont
malheureusement pas permis de les
discuter et je formule le vœu avec
Olivier du soft que la suite de la
navette parlementaire permettent de les
inscrire dans le marbre de la loi la
question de la retraite des femmes
restera bien sûr dans les débats
parlementaires donnant lieu à des
interrogations légitimes mais aussi à
des mauvais procès et des informations
trompeuses tout cela suscitant en retour
de l'incompréhension parmi nos
concitoyens et surtout nos concitoyennes
nous voulons les dissiper cette réforme
prend en compte les parcours des femmes
d'abord rappelons-le les femmes
partiront plus tôt à la retraite que les
hommes et continueront de percevoir leur
retraite plus longtemps que les hommes
jusqu'à présent les femmes partent
actuellement en moyenne plus tard que
les hommes à la retraite cette inégalité
vient bien entendu d'une égalité d'une
inégalité dans la vie active et non d'un
traitement spécifique du système des
retraites pour les femmes
c'est des parts retardés sont le fait
des interruptions que vous avez souligné
des interruptions de carrière plus
nombreuses plus longues pour les femmes
en moyenne la meilleure conciliation
entre maternité et vie professionnelle
permise par des évolutions du marché du
travail ainsi que l'assurance vieillesse
des parents au foyer que nous renforçons
permet désormais aux femmes de moins
interrompre leur carrière ainsi les
femmes partiront progressivement plus
tôt que les hommes y compris après la
réforme une fois la réforme complètement
entrée en vigueur c'est à dire pour les
Français nés en 1972 l'âge de départ
moyen sera de 64 ans et quatre mois pour
les femmes contre 64 ans et 6 mois pour
les hommes
ce sont ces mêmes dispositifs qui
permettent aux femmes de partir
progressivement plus tôt que les hommes
qui font qu'elles devront davantage
décaler leur départ à la retraite sous
l'effet de la réforme que les hommes 9
mois en moyenne contre 5 mois pour les
hommes ce décalage ne vient pas d'une
disposition spécifique aux femmes dans
la réforme il est uniquement la
conséquence du fait que les femmes
atteignent plus facilement le taux plein
avant ou dès l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite en moyenne c'est pour éviter un
décalage plus important et repartir
l'effort entre les femmes et les hommes
que nous avons à la fois rehausser l'âge
légal et la durée d'assurance plutôt que
de porter les forces sur le seul âge
légal en le relevant à 65 ans c'est un
des points qui a été particulièrement
discuté pendant la concertation lorsque
les différents scénarios ont été
présentés aux partenaires sociaux
prioritaire à nos yeux et moins de
permettre un départ plutôt à la retraite
mais de garantir l'amélioration des
pensions des mers qui ont dû interrompre
leur activité et ont pu être pénalisés
par la suite en termes de progression
salariale nous examinerons avec
attention les propositions qui pourront
être formulées dans la suite des débats
en particulier au Sénat où nous
débuterons demain l'examen du texte en
séance cette discussion ainsi qu'une
discussion plus large sur les droits
familiaux ouvrira la voie à une réforme
d'autant plus juste pour les femmes
qu'elle vient répondre à la principale
inégalité femme homme en matière de
retraite le plus faible niveau de
pension de celle-ci
des petites pensions prévues par la
réforme en clair en revalorisant les
petites pensions ce sont notamment
celles des femmes que nous revalorisons
au global en prenant en compte toutes
les pensions pour la génération 1972 la
pension moyenne des femmes augmentera de
2,2 % soit une augmentation deux fois
plus importante que celle des hommes
avec cette augmentation la réforme
contribuera à réduire les écarts de
pension entre les femmes et les hommes
renforçant encore le mouvement impulsé
par la progressive réduction de l'écart
salarial l'écart de pension entre femmes
et hommes s'établit aujourd'hui
au-dessus de 30% pour la génération 1961
celle qui part à la retraite cette année
cet écart diminuera de 10 points pour la
génération 1971 et continuera à
décroître ensuite pour s'établir
progressivement en deçà de 20% pour les
générations pour lesquelles la réforme
joue à plein ce n'est pas le seul effet
de la réforme bien évidemment mais elle
y contribue
ainsi si la réforme augmente les
pensions pour l'ensemble des assurés
pour toutes les générations concernées
par la réforme avec un gain croissant au
fur et à mesure des générations ce sont
les femmes qui en bénéficient le plus et
le mieux je crois que nous pouvons ici
collectivement nous en réjouir
la réforme elle accompagnera également
de nouveaux droits aux femmes attendues
depuis longtemps la réforme répare une
injustice de longue date en actant la
prise en compte des congés parentaux et
plus globalement des trimestres acquis
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse des
parents au foyer la réforme permettra
que cette trimestre soit retenue pour
l'éligibilité au dispositif de carrière
longue et de retraite minimale ainsi il
rentreront désormais intégralement et
non plus partiellement dans le calcul du
minimum de pension ces congés
correspondent souvent à des
interruptions de carrière pour les
femmes et constitue une grande partie en
grande une grande partie des
interruptions et des liens liés aux
écarts de pension cette réforme
améliorera donc concrètement la prise en
compte des carrières hachées des femmes
et fera en sorte que le choix de ne
paternité ne soit pas synonyme d'un
renoncement sur sa retraite
enfin rappelons aussi que les femmes qui
ont connu de longues interruptions de
carrière n'auront pas à travailler plus
longtemps nous l'avons dit les retraites
des femmes sont plus interrompues de
manière plus ou moins choisie dans de
nombreux cas les femmes concernées
doivent travailler au-delà de l'âge
légal pour avoir une pension suffisante
pour 20% des femmes aujourd'hui c'est
même jusqu'à l'âge du taux plein pour
faire en sorte que ces interruptions
soient moins pénalisantes qu'elles ne
sont aujourd'hui l'âge du taux plein
sera maintenue à 67 ans ainsi la durée
maximale entre l'âge légal et l'âge du
taux plein et réduite d'autant que l'âge
légal est augmentée elle passe donc d'un
maximum de 5 ans à un maximum de 3 ans
pour mémoire la réforme de 2010 avait
choisi de repousser l'âge du taux plein
en même temps que l'âge légal nous
décidons de ne pas faire comme avant et
de faire mieux
en conclusion l'égalité femme homme est
une priorité de ce gouvernement
notamment au ministère du Travail et
cette réforme ne fait pas exception la
réforme que nous présentons fait
progresser la situation de nombreuses
femmes à la retraite elle améliore les
retraites de celles qui ont des
carrières hachées parce qu'elles ont
interrompu leur carrière de celles qui
ont commencé plus tôt de celles qui ont
et de celles qui ont de faibles revenus
bien entendu il subsiste des inégalités
cette réforme elle ne peut pas à elle
seule corriger intégralement celle du
marché du travail la priorité est donc
de continuer à se battre pour l'égalité
professionnelle femme homme en termes de
salaire quand autant en termes de
carrière nous poursuivrons donc une
approche déterminée engagée sous le
précédent un quinquennat par le
Président de la République notamment
autour de l'index d'égalité
professionnelle ou encore des mesures
encourageant à accélérer l'égalité
économique et professionnelle car le
sujet d'égalité famome dans
l'émancipation économique démarre dès
l'orientation et se joue tout au long de
la carrière pour se retrouver évidemment
au moment de la retraite je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre
nous avons venons maintenant aux
questions je vous rappelle que la durée
des questions et de deux minutes et
celle des réponses limitées également à
deux minutes alors pour le groupe la
France insoumise nuque madame Élise le
boucher
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le 26 février Olivier du sof
déclaré sur BFM TV qu'avoir des âges de
départ différenciés entre les femmes et
les hommes ce n'est pas très juste
j'admire son sens de l'euphémisme en
effet ce n'est pas très juste que les
femmes partent plus tard à la retraite
que les hommes en raison des carrières
hachées et du système injuste de décote
ce n'est pas juste non plus que les
femmes perçoivent des pensions 40%
inférieure à celle des hommes chiffres
qui s'élève à 28% en incluant les
pensions de réversion ce n'est toujours
pas juste quand le taux de pauvreté
atteint 10% pour les femmes retraitées
et que les femmes seules représentent
50% des allocataires du minimum
vieillesse
vous le voyez par les sondages à travers
les mobilisations les Françaises et les
Français sont claires dans le rejet de
cette réforme vous pouvez encore sortir
par le haut et retirer ce projet funeste
mais nous devons aller encore plus loin
il est anormal que les femmes touchent
des pensions de misère et soient plonger
dans la précarité à la retraite pour les
femmes notre système de protection
sociale se base encore trop souvent sur
les droits dérivés liés au conjoint au
lieu de protéger les droits propres des
femmes compter uniquement sur les
pensions de réversion pour garantir de
retraites digne ces anti-féministe il
est urgent de sortir de ce système
patriarcal de faire évoluer notre
protection sociale alors que les femmes
sont pleinement dans le monde du travail
alors que devons-nous faire tout d'abord
renforcer les droits propres éliminer
les dispositifs qui discriminent les
carrières hachées comme la décote mais
on doit traiter le problème à la racine
les inégalités salariales sont à la base
des écarts de pension il est urgent
d'adopter une politique de l'emploi pour
contrer leur précarisation des femmes
qui sont particulièrement affectées par
les temps partiels de revaloriser les
métiers majoritairement occupés par des
femmes et de prendre des mesures pour
favoriser l'accès pour rappel la France
est 25e sur 38 au sein de l'OCDE en
termes de taux d'emploi des femmes si le
taux d'activité était égal entre les
femmes et les hommes 1,1 million de
femmes en plus travaillera et cotiserait
l'égalité salariale entre femmes et
hommes rapportera minima 5,5 milliards
d'euros de cotisations permettant de
revaloriser les pensions voici nos
propositions les solutions sont devant
vous que comptez-vous faire pour faire
sortir nos retraits du patriarcat dans
l'attente d'une réponse satisfaisante
nous resterons mobilisés dès mardi
prochain et le 8 mars lors de la grève
féministe
merci la parole est à madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée vous m'interrogez finalement sur
la philosophie générale de cette réforme
et je tiens à vous redire à quel point
dans le système actuel les femmes déjà
attendent beaucoup plus souvent là je
maximale pour ne pas avoir la décote et
que cet âge restera celui de 67 ans
aussi pour protéger les femmes que ce
sont elles qui ont le plus souvent des
plus petites retraites et que cette
réforme elle viendra travailler sur cet
écart de pension entre les femmes et les
hommes que j'évoquais à l'instant à ce
jour je le rappelle l'écart de pension
est autour de 30% et nous visons un
écart de pension à l'horizon 2030 qui
sera autour de deux de 20% pardon avec
une meilleure prise en compte des congés
parentaux et des congés procédants avec
la volonté de travailler sur ce minimum
de pension qui bénéficiera plus
largement aux femmes 60% des femmes sont
concernées par ces minimum de pension au
ce que je veux vous dire par l'ensemble
de ces éléments c'est que au-delà de
leur pension augmenter et là aussi en
moyenne 6% pour les femmes contre un peu
moins pour les hommes c'est je vous le
rappelle un ensemble de mesures que nous
avons prises pour travailler à la source
sur ce sujet dès la loi de 2018 qui
s'appelle liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel le titre 3 relatif
notamment à l'index d'égalité
professionnelle entre les hommes et les
femmes vient accompagner certaines
exigences et à travailler sur les axes
que nous abordons aujourd'hui travailler
sur ces inégalités de rémunération mais
également de carrière je souhaiterais
également citer la loi de 2021 visant à
accélérer l'émancipation économique et
professionnelle des femmes et des hommes
et verser vers plus d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dans leur parcours
de carrière leur responsabilité car là
aussi bien sûr c'est un enjeu
merci la parole est à Monsieur William
Martinez
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mon propos portera sur votre
refus de prendre en compte la pénibilité
des métiers féminisés dans votre réforme
des retraites avec comme conséquence
d'aggraver les inégalités la situation
des femmes sur le marché du travail
aujourd'hui se dégrade entre 2001 et
2015 le nombre d'accidents du travail
avec arrêt à diminuer de 28% chez les
hommes mais à augmenter dans la même
proportion chez les femmes ces chiffres
ils sont évidemment problématiques ils
sont le fruit de l'histoire du monde du
travail parce que il est vrai que la
prévention des risques professionnels
elle s'est d'abord construite dans les
branches professionnelles du bâtiment de
la chimie de la métallurgie qui sont des
broches professionnelles masculines mais
madame la ministre le l'histoire
n'excuse pas tout nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2023 il serait temps de
prendre conscience que la moitié des
travailleurs sont des travailleuses et
que elle aussi ont le droit à une
prévention des risques professionnels et
à une reconnaissance de leur
malheureusement cette prise de
conscience apparemment ne s'est pas
faite dans les rangs macronistes et je
vais citer des exemples très concrets
par exemple le compte prévention
professionnelle de Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron mis en place en 2017 sur les six
critères de ce compte de prévention
professionnelle un seul critère concerne
majoritairement les femmes il s'agit des
gestes répétitifs je vais être même plus
précis et vous expliquer le processus
par lequel ces critères peuvent exclure
les femmes prenons le cas du critère
port de charge lourdes et bien une
hôtesse de caisse métier quasi
exclusivement féminin une hôtesse de
caisse elle porte une tonne de charges
par jour mais le mode de calcul de ce
critère ce sont des poids unitaires et
non pas des poids cumulés et donc une
hôtesse de caisse qui porte une tonne
par jour elle n'est pas éligible aux
critères port de charge lourdes ce qui
est absolument aberrant je peux rajouter
rapidement la question de la pénibilité
psychologique qui concerne beaucoup de
métiers du lien avec des femmes qui sont
confrontées à la détresse sociale mais
pour finir je dirais madame la ministre
qu'avez-vous fait pour corriger ce
manque de prise en compte de la
pénibilité des métiers féminisés rien et
c'est même pire que ça là la meilleure
des préventions c'est de pouvoir partir
à la retraite avant que le travail est
cassé notre corps et cassé notre esprit
et quand vous reculez l'âge de départ à
la retraite vous aggraver la situation
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Martinet écoutez plusieurs choses
déjà en préalable je regrette que c'est
des balades n'aient pas pu se tenir dans
le cadre d'une discussion sur les
retraites qui a été organisée et bloqué
par votre groupe c'est fort dommage
parce que je pense qu'effectivement ici
sur ces bancs beaucoup de gens aurait
souhaité beaucoup de députés auraient
souhaité participer à cette discussion
je voudrais vous rappeler que les
députés de la majorité ont vrai en
matière de santé au travail par une loi
de 2021 que peut-être vous n'avez pas
encore eu le temps de découvrir mais je
voulais la rappellerai visant à
accélérer l'amélioration de la
prévention en santé au travail j'en
étais moi-même la co-autrice et donc je
peux vous dire que cette loi visait à
accompagner effectivement la santé au
travail de tous les travailleurs
travailleuses comme travailleur
alors vous m'interrogez sur ce projet
défendu par le gouvernement qui renforce
la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle par tous les leviers
disponibles alors bien sûr le débat
l'indique
consacré finalement son son thème sur la
pénibilité qui a été organisé à
l'initiative du groupe écologiste a
permis de rappeler plusieurs éléments et
je vais ici les redire d'abord
l'amélioration des droits du compte
professionnel de prévention au sein
duquel figure bien évidemment les femmes
qui représentent environ un quart des
personnes exposées soit environ 160
000 personnes le nombre des points
pouvant être acquis va donc être des
plafonné monsieur et la valeur des
points pour l'utilisation des formations
et le temps partiel va être augmenté de
30%. evidemment cette mesure vous êtes
pas sans le savoir bénéficiera donc
particulièrement aux femmes ensuite un
engageant une mobilisation inédite avec
la création d'un fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle un milliard d'euros je
vous le rappelle sur le quinquennat se
font sera donc consacré à la prévention
de l'usure dans les métiers exposés au
port de charge lourdes aux postures
pénibles aux vibrations mécaniques
auxquelles sont particulièrement
exposées les femmes très consacrètement
une aide-soignante par exemple aura des
droits à formation professionnelle et
adaptation de leur poste de travail
supplémentaire
la parole est maintenant au groupe les
républicains avec Madame Emilie Bonivard
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre depuis 2017 et dans la foulée
de François Hollande Emmanuel Macron a
poursuivi la destruction de la politique
familiale française en baissant le
plafond de la prestation d'accueil du
jeune enfant qui ne facilite pas le
travail des femmes en ne remettant pas
en place l'universalité des allocations
familiales et en continuant à renier sur
le quotient familial ce sont les
familles les plus particulièrement les
femmes qui travaillent et qui veulent
avoir des enfants qui ont été pénalisés
par ces choix nous avons cette année
atteint le triste record en France du
niveau le plus bas de natalité il ne
faut pas s'en étonner c'est aussi la
conséquence de ces choix nous
n'accompagnons pas les femmes pour leur
permettre de mener dans le même temps
une vie familiale une vie de mer et une
vie professionnelle épanouie c'est aussi
l'avenir de notre pays sa puissance et
notre système de solidarité et de
retraite qui sont en jeu malheureusement
la réforme des retraites prend le relais
de ces mesures et suppriment la pleine
reconnaissance de la maternité dans
notre système de retraite ma question
est simple comment allez-vous corriger
madame la ministre les effets négatifs
du projet de loi pour la retraite des
femmes qui ont eu des enfants il est
impératif que d'une manière ou d'une
autre soit financièrement par une
amélioration des pensions de leur
pension et ou en agissant sur l'âge de
départ et ou de retraite à taux plein la
grossesse et l'éducation des enfants
soient mieux pris en compte dans cette
réforme quid de la proposition des
républicains
d'apporter une surcote de 5% pour les
maires de famille qui auraient atteint à
la fois une carrière complète et l'âge
légal ou un départ à la retraite
anticipée à 63 ans pour les femmes qui
ont eu des carrières hachées qui se sont
arrêtées pour élever leurs enfants et
qui sont sur représentés parmi les
Français devant travailler jusqu'à 67
ans et qui ont aussi les pensions les
plus faibles en raison souvent de temps
partiel quid d'un abaissement de l'âge
de de d'effacement de 67 à 65 ans pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein et ou également d'une surcote je
vous remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée bonivar au fond plusieurs cas de
figure dans ce que ce que ce sur quoi
vous m'interrogez le cas des carrières
complètes avec parfois des trimestres en
sucs à majoration de durée d'assurance
qui deviennent du coup obsolètes du fait
de l'absence d'interruption de carrière
ou au contraire de fortes interruptions
qui de carrière qui doivent du coup
contraindre la personne de travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour pouvoir bénéficier
du temps plein concernant le premier
point c'est le sens d'un amendement voté
en commission des affaires sociales au
Sénat qui permet pour les femmes qui ont
l'ensemble de leur trimestre et des
majorations pour enfants de surcoter un
an un an avant l'âge légal c'est une
disposition sur laquelle la première
ministre s'est exprimée en étant
favorable à cette discussion pour
poursuivre effectivement des avancées
vis-à-vis de de ces futurs retraités
concernant le second point porté à 65
ans l'âge du Taupin des finances
financièrement pas viable effectivement
on estime le surcoût d'une telle mesure
à plus de 10 milliards par an ce qui ne
rend évidemment pas viable
financièrement cette proposition
néanmoins le projet soutenu par le
gouvernement prévoit des mesures à
faciliter les parcours à taux plein par
la création de l'assurance vieillesse
des aidants par exemple ou par la
facilitation de rachat de trimestre pour
études supérieures et de stage qui
viennent accompagner finalement cette
cet effort pour accompagner les
carrières il convient par ailleurs de
noter qu'augmenter l'âge légal à 64 ans
implique que la décote maximale passera
de 25 à 15% ainsi les femmes qui
souhaitent partir le plus tôt possible
malgré des carrières très incomplètes
portiront toujours avec une décote mais
plus faible qu'auparavant merci Madame
la Ministre la parole est au groupe
démocrate avec Madame Géraldine Bannier
madame la ministre ma question concerne
précisément la génération des femmes
agricultrices et commerçante
actuellement en retraite qui ont souvent
de faibles pensions encore bien
inférieur au minimum vieillesse de fait
de nombreuses françaises avant que une
fois créer des statuts plus stables et
protecteurs on travaillait sont toujours
cotisés le plus souvent au sein
d'entreprise que dirigeait leur père
puis Marie comme aide familiale puis
conjointe collaboratrice reprenant
parfois en leur nom l'entreprise en tant
que chef d'exploitation agricole ou
gérante et cela depuis le certificat
d'études jusqu'à leur fin de carrière
elles ont bien souvent validé leur
trimestres pas toujours pour autant
cotisés mais sont évidemment très
concernés par le sujet des petites
pensions et la pauvreté à l'heure où
sonne la retraite alors que va changer
pour elle la réforme en cours
pourront-elles être concernés par la
revalorisation du minimum contributif
quel serait le nombre de ces femmes qui
pourraient voir leur pensions
revalorisées on sait bien que l'objectif
d'une pension minimale à 1200 euros pour
une carrière complète à temps plein au
SMIC et particulièrement compliqué à
atteindre pour ces femmes elles étaient
souvent mal Ré créé en deçà du SMIC et
n’était pas toujours en capacité de
pouvoir cotiser sujet de nos
prédécesseurs ont bien trop longtemps
occulté le dispositif ne concernera pour
ainsi dire que les futurs retraités mais
ces femmes pourront-elles bénéficier de
l'augmentation du socle de base du
minimum contributif de 25 euros et sa
majoration pour laquelle il faut au
moins 120 trimestres cotisés de 75 euros
j'ai cru comprendre qu'une pension
liquide à taux plein mais pas forcément
avec tous les trimestres cotisés
pourraient permettre aux agricultrices
de bénéficier de cette revalorisation
est-ce la même chose pour les
commerçantes c'est un sujet évidemment
où les réponses sont très attendues dans
nos territoires pouvez-vous éclairer la
représentation nationale sur le sujet
merci madame la députée la parole est à
madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée Bannier les femmes conjointe
collaboratrices qu'elles soient ancienne
agricultrice ou indépendante ont en
effet des pensions particulièrement
faibles du fait des faibles cotisations
acquittées rappelons d'abord les
avancées votées sous le précédent
quinquennat notamment dans le cadre de
la seconde loi chassen adoptée à
l'unanimité avec le soutien du
gouvernement qui prévoit un minimum de
pension de base et non salariés agricole
qui bénéficie notamment au conjoint de
collaboratrice et aux aidants qui a été
revalorisés c'est environ 200 000
bénéficiaires dont 60% de femmes qui
sont concernés avec un gain moyen de 70
euros par mois dont 30% sont au dessus
des 100 euros par mois le deuxième point
que je souhaite saluer dans cette
disposition Chassaigne c'est le statut
du conjoint collaborateur qui a été
encadré pour les agriculteurs et les
artisans commerçants pour limiter ce
statut à 5 ans maximum et éviter
l'enfermement dans un statut faiblement
générateur de droit
concernant les mesures de revalorisation
des petites pensions prévues dans le
projet de loi le minimum de pension va
augmenter autant au régime général que
dans le régime agricole et donc pour les
commerçants artisans notamment dans les
deux cas les trimestres de conjoints
collaborateurs sont considérés comme des
trimestres cotisés la hausse sera donc
bien calculée sur la base de plus 100
euros par mois en fonction des durées et
des profils de carrière si sur la
question des anciens agriculteurs que
vous mentionnez il s'agit d'un
dispositif spécifique de la loi chassa
saigne 1 qui vise les anciens
exploitants qui ont parfois été conjoint
collaborateurs avant la loi prévoyait
que seuls ceux qui avaient le taux plein
pour la durée c'est à dire tous les
trimestres avaient droit à la garantie
spécifique à 85% du SMIC net agricole du
régime nous supprimons cette disposition
pour ouvrir le dispositif à ceux qui ont
aussi eu le taux plein pour d'autres
raisons par exemple l'invalidité ou
l'âge cela permettra à 45
000 personnes de voir leur post
augmenter d'environ 80 euros par mois en
moyenne merci madame la ministre pour le
groupe socialiste et apparenté la parole
est à Monsieur Bertrand petit merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
dans huit jours très précisément
mercredi prochain 8 mars nous
célébrerons la journée internationale
des droits des femmes parmi ces droits
il y a celui à un salaire égal or en
matière de salaire comment matière de
retraite force et de constater quelles
sont les éternels laissés pour compte
les chiffres sont les chiffres sont
d'ailleurs là pour le rappeler des
salaires inférieurs en moyenne de 22% à
ceux des hommes des pensions inférieures
de 40% à celles versées aux hommes 70%
des bénéficiaires du minimum pension
sont des femmes parmi le million de
retraités pauvres 76% sont des femmes
neuf réformes des retraites en 50 ans
n'auront pas suffi à réduire ces
inégalités au mieux aller freiner votre
réforme n'y changera rien bien au
contraire puisque 60% du coût de cette
réforme sera apporté par les femmes
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
pénalise les personnes qui ont des
carrières courtes ou hachées et qui
déjeunent atteignent pas la durée de
cotisation exigée ce sont en majorité
des femmes dans le calcul de la retraite
deux choses sont plus discriminantes
pour la pour les carrières courtes le
calcul sur les 25 meilleures années et
la décote c'est une double
discrimination pour les carrières
incomplètes et ce sont les femmes les
plus touchées tous les spécialistes
s'accordent à dire que pour réduire les
inégalités au niveau des retraites des
femmes il faut s'attaquer à tout ce qui
vient avant et pendant l'activité
professionnelle réduire voire supprimer
les inégalités salariales s'attaquer à
la question des pénalités que subissent
les femmes quand elles sont maires à ce
titre j'ai lu avec intérêt les
déclarations de Monsieur le Ministre du
Travail dans un article du journal Le
Monde où il indiquait vouloir permettre
au maire de famille de choisir entre des
trimestres pour maternité et une
majoration de leur pension à la carte
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous en
dire plus sur vos intentions précises à
ce sujet et en quoi ces dispositions
seraient réellement de nature à rétablir
les femmes dans leur droit et surtout de
mettre un terme à ces inégalités par
ailleurs pouvez-vous m'indiquer si de
telle mesure s'appliqueront à
distinctement pour les femmes
travaillant dans le secteur privé comme
dans le secteur public merci monsieur le
député la parole est à madame la
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député petit vous m'interrogez sur la
possibilité au fond de choisir entre les
trimestres de maternité et des
majorations de pensions votre question
est souligne le fait que les droits
familiaux actuels ne sont pas mobilisés
de la même manière pour chacun et on
estime en fait que près de d'un tiers
des femmes qui partent à la retraite le
font avec des majorations déjà en SUP
des obligations qu'elles doivent pouvoir
avoir et ce phénomène il va se renforcer
les années à venir y compris en raison
de la plus grande participation des
femmes sur le marché du travail le droit
d'option entre majoration de pensions
dès le premier enfant et une majoration
de durée d'assurance est une piste de
réflexion d'ailleurs plutôt nouvelle qui
viendra renforcer les options qui
existent déjà la majoration éducation
peut-être partagée par exemple entre les
deux parents par exemple et à cet égard
elle pourra faire partie de nouvelles
étudier dans le cadre du rapport sur les
droits familiaux et conjugaux afin
d'estimer notamment les effets
financiers et redistributifs mais aussi
de lisibilité du système de retraite un
rapport qui sera remis au Parlement à
l'issue de ces travaux pour permettre de
poursuivre les avancées je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
horizon et à parenté la parole est à
Madame Anne-Cécile violon
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre dans la prolongation de mon
interpellation sur la nécessité de
traiter la problématique des inégalités
de retraite par la racine je vous
propose d'envisager cette question sous
l'impérieuse obligation de traiter les
inégalités salariales
je recevais en début d'après-midi une
classe de ma circonscription du Chablais
et je suis interrogée par une jeune
fille de 15 ans qui me demande si c'est
bien les députés qui votent les lois et
elle me dit mais alors pourquoi les
femmes sont-elles moins rémunérées que
les hommes réellement début d'après-midi
que répondre à cette jeune fille qui
effectivement ne peut comprendre cette
état de Total injustice alors je vous
propose un axe de réflexion mis en place
en 2019 par la loi avenir professionnel
l'index de l'égalité professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes appelés
aussi index Pénicaud permet de mesurer
les inégalités salariales au sein des
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés il
vise à supprimer ses écarts de
rémunération entre les hommes et les
femmes et donc il s'articule autour de
cinq critères les écarts de rémunération
les écarts entre les augmentations
annuelles les écarts entre les
promotions les augmentations retours de
congé maternité la part des femmes dans
les plus hautes rémunération
l'entreprise et tout cela doit être
publié par alors certes la mise en place
de cet index a permis une avancée dans
cette égalité professionnelle néanmoins
je crois que ça a été suffisamment
répété aujourd'hui les femmes restent
bien moins rémunérées que les hommes
ne serait-il pas pertinent de durcir les
contraintes et les pénalités financières
de cette index afin qu'un puisse un jour
ne plus du tout avoir à traiter cette
question de l'inégalité salariale je
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée violent voilà une conviction que
nous partageons et une difficulté à
expliquer effectivement aux jeunes
générations cette difficulté de salaire
elle est parfaitement inacceptable elle
est prévue par la loi et pour autant ce
n'est pas si facile à faire appliquer et
c'est donc une conviction que bien sûr
nous partageons une détermination que
nous partageons pour pouvoir
effectivement faire appliquer ces
obligations légales ces obligations
légales qui expliquent aussi largement
les inégalités en matière de retraite
donc inégalité de salaire c'est
évidemment travailler le sujet à sa
racine au foncis les droits familiaux et
conjugaux permettent de réduire ses
écarts je crois que nous devons agir au
plus proche des des enjeux dès
l'orientation des des jeunes et
notamment des jeunes filles autour des
métiers d'avenir et des métiers les plus
rémunérés nous avons collectivement une
part à jouer nous allons évidemment
travailler sur cette découverte des
métiers dès le collège avec cette en jeu
de travailler sur les stéréotypes et
notamment ceux de genre mais de
travailler aussi au travers de
dispositifs et je vois monsieur le
vigourux ici présent de dispositif tels
que le mentorat pour accompagner les
jeunes et les jeunes filles à avoir
l'ambition de partir dans des carrières
qui sont aujourd'hui reconnues comme
étant prometteuses et notamment en terme
de rémunération alors si un texte de
rémunération l'égalité femme homme et
aujourd'hui une réalité la plupart
maintenant des entreprises déclare cette
index s'il commence à faire ses effets
aussi je me permets de le dire la DARES
nous a sorti quelques études montrant
que entre 2017 et 2019 nous sommes
passés d'un écart de salaire entre les
femmes et les hommes à effectif temps
plein de 16,8 à 16,1%, on voit
l'accélération 2019-2020 puisqu'on est
passé de 16,1% d'écart à 14,8% des cas
et donc cette accélération il faut qu'on
la renforce parce que nous devons
atteindre le zéro écart de rémunération
pour effectivement atteindre cette
ambition du 0 et de pension et c'est
bien à notre objectif commun et notre
détermination collective je crois ici
[Musique]
la parole pour le et maintenant au
groupe écologie et elle est à madame la
Présidente Cyrielle châtelain merci
madame la Présidente
sur le projet des retraites le
gouvernement nous a habitué aux Frost
promesses que nous avons pu ici même
dans l'hémicycle dévoilés la première
d'entre elles ce sont les 1200 euros
donc on a bien compris que tant de
femmes ne toucheront pas parce que elles
ont eu le malheur ou en tout cas ils ont
été contraintes de travailler à temps
partiel l'autre chose madame la ministre
est finalement ce que vous avez dit non
cette les premières bénéficiaires de
cette réforme ne seront pas les femmes
au contraire elles vont être les
premières pénalisées et vous avez
rappelé le débat que nous avons eu en
début de semaine sur la question de la
pénibilité effectivement nous avions une
représentante des auxiliaires de vie
Madame Anne le seigle qui a rappelé
aujourd'hui que ce compte de pénibilité
elle ne concerne pas les auxiliaires de
vie qu'aujourd'hui les pénibilités
qu'elles ont dans les charges lourdes
dans les positionnements dans les
cadences aujourd'hui ne sont pas pris en
compte et qu'en vrai elle ne peuvent pas
aller jusqu'à 64 ans c'était ça leur
message c'était on est épuisé fatigué
moralement nerveusement physiquement
les chiffres vont quand même largement
contre vous Miquel Zemmour dont on a
beaucoup parlé des travaux a aussi
regardé sur qui les économies portaient
puisque finalement cette réforme des
retraites c'est une mesure d'économie ça
vise à ce que les gens travaillent plus
longtemps quand ils disent plus
longtemps pour que les tables puissent
moins dépenser d'argent public et il est
très clair ce sont les femmes qui vont
sur lesquels vont poser 60 % des
économies immédiates Léo décalage de
l'âge de départ à la retraite il prend
un exemple très simple c'est la
génération de 1972 sur cette génération
alors que les femmes ont des pensions
moins de c'est à dire à peu près moins
de 30% que les hommes et ben elles vont
travailler 9 mois de plus et en
travaillant neuf mois de plus en fait il
y aura plus de 12000 euros qui seront
fait d'économiser sur le dos de chaque
femme née en 1972 et c'est beaucoup plus
que sur les hommes puisqu'en fait les
hommes ne travailleront en moyenne que 5
mois de plus donc madame je vous demande
en fait aujourd'hui de reconnaître la
vérité pouvez-vous nous confirmer ces
chiffres et enfin reconnaître que les
économies faites sont faites sur le dos
des femmes
merci Madame le député la parole est à
madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée châtelain votre question est
simple ma réponse le saura tout autant
le bilan financier de la réforme on
incluant les mesures d'accompagnement
présentées dans le texte initial
notamment celle de la revalorisation des
petites retraites montre qu'à l'horizon
2030 la répartition du rendement entre
les femmes et les hommes et parfaitement
équilibré 50
merci pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine la parole est à Madame
Soumia Bourou a merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre dans la
continuité des travaux qui ont été menés
par le président de mon groupe André
chassen et près d'un an après l'adoption
définitive de sa loi visant assurer la
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
à hauteur de 80% du SMIC pour une
carrière complète de chef des
prestations nous avions défendu une
proposition de loi visant à reconnaître
à sa juste valeur le travail des
conjoints collaborateurs et aide
familiaux la pension mensuelle des
intéressés s'élevée en moyenne au
quatrième trimestre 2020 à 574 euros
pour les conjoints ayant validé au moins
150 trimestres et 716 euros pour les
membres de la famille ayant validé au
moins 150 trimestres le montant de la
pension de ces travailleurs pouvant être
plus faibles encore principalement pour
ce n'ayant pas validé suffisamment de
trimestres cette seconde loi Chassaigne
a prévu une revalorisation mensuelle de
100 euros en moyenne depuis le 1er
janvier 2022 de ces quelques 210000
210000 retraités qui sont à 67% des
femmes si cette nouvelle loi fruit d'une
mobilisation collective et continue des
retraités agricoles représentent une
avancée beaucoup restent à faire pour
garantir à toutes et à tous ces
retraités une retraite digne aussi ma
question est simple quelle initiative le
gouvernement entendit le prendre pour
revaloriser les pensions de ces femmes
conjointe collaboratrices aux carrières
souvent hachées et réduire les
inégalités qui subsistent avec les
retraités du régime général je vous
remercie merci la parole est à madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée Bourgois vous l'avez dit lors de
la précédente mandature une proposition
de loi dédiée aux pensions de conjoint
collaborateurs agricole avait été adopté
à l'unanimité avec le soutien du
gouvernement il s'agit ainsi d'une
revalorisation sans précédent qui a
permis à plus de 200 000 pardon anciens
conjoint collaborateurs ou aide
familiaux le plus souvent des femmes de
voir leur pensions revalorisées mais en
effet il faut aussi prendre en compte
des mesures pour que les futurs
retraites soient meilleurs et que les
écarts avec les salariés se réduisent
deux éléments à apporter par rapport à
cela d'abord le fait que depuis cette
même loi Chassaigne le statut de
conjoint collaborateur est encadré à 5
ans maximum à l'issue il faudra choisir
un statut qui soit davantage valorisant
et surtout créateur de droits associés
ou salarié et ensuite parce que les
hausses des minimas de pension jusqu'à
plus de 100 euros par mois pour les
futurs retraités ayant une carrière
complète s'appliquera aussi au minimum
de pensions de base des non salariés
agricoles et donc au conjoint
collaborateur qui partiront à la
retraite à compter du premier septembre
2023 je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est
au groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoire avec Monsieur Charles de
Courson
madame la ministre
dans le projet de loi sur les retraites
rien sur les pensions de réversion
or
les pensions de réversion selon les 42
régimes sont parfois sous conditions
d'âge parfois sans condition d'âge c'est
55 ans dans une général mais dans les
régimes spéciaux il y a pas de
conditions d'âge parfois subordonnée à
des conditions de plafonnement entre les
droits propres et les pensions de
réversion la fondement par exemple dans
le régime général et pas de plafonnement
dans les régimes spéciaux plus
généralement plus les régimes sont
favorables plus les conditions d'octroi
des pensions de réversion sont libérales
et plus le régime sont défavorables plus
les conditions sont dures
alors madame la ministre la question est
toute simple est-ce que le gouvernement
est ouvert au rétablissement du principe
d'égalité en matière de pension de
réversion quel que soit le régime
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député de Courson au fond votre question
m'interrogeant sur le système de
réversion vient effectivement interrogé
bien au-delà finalement des questions
financières une dimension sociétale qui
est au cœur de nos réflexions bien sûr
car il touche ici on touche à la vision
même que l'on donne à la pension de
réversion d'une part et quelque part au
mariage d'autre part des évolutions qui
méritent donc à la fois des réflexions
et des débats approfondis mais aussi des
études d'impact sur les effets
redistributifs prenons par exemple le
cas de l'ouverture de la réversion au
couple pacsé vous le savez aujourd'hui
il y a une pluralité de conjoint
survivant la pension de réversion est
partagée entre les conjoints si on ouvre
la pension de réversion en couple qui
ont été PACS faut-il par exemple prévoir
un partage de la veuve qui a été marié
avec le défunt avec l'ancienne conjointe
qui a été pacsé par le passé voilà sans
évidemment des questions qui sont
complexes à aborder
qui doivent de notre point de vue être
étudiés dans le cas du rapport dédié à
la refonte des droits familiaux qui
doivent finalement travailler ensemble
sur une question plus profonde sociétale
du comment est-ce que on accompagne ces
enjeux là et c'est donc tout le rapport
tout le sens du rapport qui est proposé
en la matière sur la refonte des droits
familiaux je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est
au groupe Renaissance alors avec
Monsieur Fabrice le vigoureux
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues courrier
d'électrices et des lecteurs de
Ouest-France hier matin mardi 28 février
2023 un témoignage d'une certaine
Cristelle qui résonne et reprend une
préoccupation de beaucoup de femmes que
nous avons reçues sur tous les bancs ici
dans nos circonscriptions je suis né en
1968 j'ai 4 trimestres cotisés avant
l'âge de 20 ans donc pas de carrière
longue puis je compte 4 trimestres par
an jusqu'à 64 ans et une majoration de
24 trimestres pour mes trois enfants
résultat
204 trimestres à 64 ans je perds donc le
bénéfice des trimestres de maternité
d'éducation qui passe à la trappe oui
comme Christelle beaucoup de femmes
attachées à la sauvegarde du régime de
retraite par répartition m'ont dit
Monsieur le Député je comprends les
évolutions démographiques je sais qu'il
y a de moins en moins d'actifs pour
financer de plus en plus de retraités
beaucoup comprennent que si nous voulons
préserver le niveau des pensions sans
alourdir des prélèvements déjà très
élevés sur les actifs ou sur ceux qui
les emploie nous devons collectivement
accepter de travailler un peu plus
longtemps mais ces femmes m'ont dit
aussi j'ai eu des enfants et des
majorations de trimestres à ce titre qui
compenser une carrière freinée des
opportunités de progression
professionnelle moins nombreuses des
salaires qui nous suivaient pas la même
courbe que mes collègues hommes ou mes
collègues tout courts qui n'ont pas
connu les joies mais aussi les exigences
et les renoncements que supposent
l'accueil d'un enfant dans son foyer
cette question des trimestres en trop
pour de nombreuses femmes non pris en
compte aujourd'hui et au cœur des
articles 7 et 8 de la réforme des
retraites nous souhaitions la débattre
dans cette assemblée j'avais porté un
amendement pour cela avec 43 de mes
collègues de la majorité nous en avons
été empêchés par l'obstruction pitoyable
de quelques députés les filles et leurs
milliers d'amendements identiques je me
réjouis néanmoins que ce sujet s'annonce
au cœur des débats du Sénat et que le
ministre du socle se soit montré très
ouvert à ce qu'il y ait des avancées en
la matière alors madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que des
contreparties sous forme de majoration
pension ou de départ anticipés sont à
l'étude pour toutes ces femmes qui parce
qu'elles ont travaillé toute leur vie en
éduquant leurs enfants ont beaucoup plus
que les trimestres qui au moment de leur
retraite je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député la parole est à madame la
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député le vigoureux au fond le
témoignage que vous donnez il est il met
effectivement le en exergue un phénomène
qui est déjà assez courant celui des
majorations de durée d'assurance en
suçues
du fait de carrière déjà complète en
effet du fait de la plus grande
participation des femmes au marché du
travail les majorations de durée
d'assurance créé dans les années 70 pour
compenser des trous de carrière et
faciliter des départs à taux plein
viennent de plus en plus s'ajouter en
fait à des carrières déjà complètes
aujourd'hui on estime environ 30% de
femmes qui ont des majorations de ce
type en dessus finalement et ce
phénomène est appelé à se renforcer j'ai
évidemment à l'esprit la démarche
collective que vous avez menée monsieur
le vigoureux monsieur le député vous
avez accompagné effectivement cette
question de réflexion générale sur les
droits familiaux et conjugaux avec cette
volonté d'accompagner aussi cette
réalité
et si effectivement deux visions peuvent
être proposées celles de départ anticipé
du fait de la maternité et effectivement
l'amendement qui avait été déposé était
dans ce sens ou celle d'augmenter des
pensions des femmes concernées le
gouvernement privilégie la seconde
option pour atteindre justement
l'égalité des pensions entre les femmes
et les hommes dans un souci de pouvoir
d'achat de d'égalité de pension entre
les femmes et les hommes et je sais que
vous-même et les députés de la majorité
ont porté ce sujet essentiel et légitime
qu'est la retraite des femmes et je me
réjouis qu'aujourd'hui vous puissiez
être accompagné dans sa dynamique et
qu'il puisse être repris sous cette
proposition de surcote par le Sénat sous
cette impulsion commune le débat
parlementaire doit maintenant permettre
de faire avancer ce sujet pour aller
vers plus de justice sociale en ce sens
je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur belle
qui est belle Haddad merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues les débats l'assemblée nation
ale sur la réforme des retraites
n'auront pas permis
faute d'options permanente d'examiner
l'ensemble des situations et des mesures
proposées je pense plus particulièrement
la situation des femmes nous connaissons
tous le constat lié aux inégalités
femmes qui augmentent par les chiffres
et autres rapports et au-delà des
situations humaines que nous touchons du
doigt dans le cadre de nos mandats des
avancées sont proposés dans le texte
consacré au projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale vous
savez si ces avancées sont des graines
sommets dans la voie à poursuivre en
matière de réduction des inégalités
femmes hommes ces inégalités constater
tout au long de la vie traduisent au
moment du départ à la à la retraite une
vraie injustice je sais le souci
permanent du gouvernement et de sa
majorité car c'est le mien également de
gommer ces injustices et ses inégalités
professionnelles mais vous le
reconnaissez tout à fait cela ne va pas
assez vite n'ayons pas pu comme beaucoup
de mes collègues des formes une série
d'amendements à ce sujet je souhaiterais
madame la ministre que le gouvernement
puisse confirmer son engagement à
prendre ses disposition s nécessaires
pour en terminer avec ces inégalités à
la fois salariales sur les carrières
interrompues ou sur les questions de
pénibilité
un sujet au sujet précisément des
pensions je souhaiterais exposer la
situation liée aux pensions de réversion
source d'inégalités entre les régimes
tenant aux conditions d'âge de
ressources de durée de mariage de non
remariages sans parler des méthodes de
calcul qui sont nombreuses sont je crois
au nombre de 13 il y a trois ans au
moment de présenter le système universel
de retraite il avait été évoqué la
question de pouvoir remplacer ses règles
par une augmentation du montant de
pension passant de 54% à
70%, cette mesure permettait de garantir
le meilleur revenu à la personne
survivante majoritairement avec les
femmes
pouvez-vous me confirmer nous confirmer
comment vous comptez
comment vous comptez procéder et comment
nous préciser la manière de d'aller sur
ce sujet très prochainement et si le
principe de ces pensions sera étendu au
couple PACS si Monsieur le Député la
parole est à madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député belladad au fond vous avez deux
propositions celle de revoir les
pensions de réversion pour garantir le
maintien du niveau de vie à 70% des deux
pensions du couple plutôt que de
redonner une fraction de la pension du
défunt et puis l'autre détendre les
pensions de réversion en couple pacsé
je voudrais dire que effectivement ces
deux sujets ont été particulièrement
abordés par les partenaires sociaux
notamment durant le second cycle de
concertation dédié à l'équité et à la
justice sociale il y avait une forme de
consensus lors de ces discussions et sur
ces deux questions dans les deux cas
finalement bien au-delà des questions
financières c'est une question sociétale
qui est posée ici avec une vision qui
doit pouvoir être pensé collectivement
sur la place qu'on donne à la pension de
réversion d'une part et au mariage
quelque part d'autre part des évolutions
qui méritent donc à la fois des
réflexions et des débats approfondis y
compris sur les effets redistributifs
c'est
des questions qui seront à aborder et
qui doivent de notre point de vue être
étudiés dans le cadre du rapport dédié à
la refonte des droits familiaux et sur
lesquels nous aurons à revenir
prochainement dans nos discussions je
vous remercie merci madame la ministre
pour le groupe rassemblement national la
parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Tachet de
la page rit madame la présidente madame
la ministre chers collègues le projet de
réforme des retraites depuis l'étude
d'impact jusqu'à nos débats dans
l'hémicycle pose un constat très clair
cette réforme est injustée brutale les
femmes seront davantage impactées par le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 62 à 64 ans elle devront travailler
en moyenne quatre mois de plus que les
hommes s'ajoutant au 10 actuels alors
même que d'après le rapport du corps
l'amélioration des carrières féminines
et la meilleure prise en compte de la
maternité tant avant cette réforme à
améliorer les pensions de retraite des
femmes à l'horizon 2050 et de rapprocher
leur retraite conjoncturelle de celle
des hommes cette dynamique positive va
être brisée car celle qui pouvait à
partir des 62 ans à taux plein grâce au
trimestre qui lors de la naissance de
leurs enfants devront désormais attendre
l'âge légal soit deux ans de plus pour
partir ayant interrogé monsieur le
ministre du soft le premier février
dernier en délégation droit des femmes
celui-ci s'est dérobé et pourtant je me
réjouis que depuis mon interpellation le
gouvernement est amandé sa position sur
la question et envisager de prendre des
mesures pour remédier à cette injustice
en effet le Ministre du soft a lui-même
admis ce dimanche qu'il fallait agir
contre l'effet de neutralisation des
trimestres validés au titre de la
maternité qui serait je cite perdu du
fait de relèvement de l'âge de départ à
la retraite la première ministre
elle-même a déclaré être favorable à une
mesure de modification des trimestres
validés par les maires de famille au
Sénat un amendement visant à ce que les
maires de famille totalisant 43 annivés
cotisations du fait de majoration de
durée d'assurance par enfant puisse
bénéficier d'une surcote à partir de 63
ans celle-ci a été adoptée
dans l'hypothèse où vous persistiez à
maintenir cette réforme des retraites
injustes pouvez-vous envisager
aujourd'hui à soutenir cet amendement ou
un lieu d'usant issu du Parlement je
vous remercie madame la ministre merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
tâché de la part de la Pagerie au fond
vous m'interrogez sur ce mécanisme qui
qui permet à certaines femmes de partir
avant aujourd'hui qui effectivement
de plus en plus ne correspond pas aux
carrières des femmes qui sont de moins
en moins incomplètes et c'est heureux
cet amendement qui a été déposé et
adopté en commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat et discuter
actuellement pour que nous puissions
soutenir des dispositions de ce type
pour la séance je tiens néanmoins à
réaffirmer que même après la réforme les
femmes partiront en moyenne plus tôt que
les hommes et je pense que c'est
important de le dire et de le redire que
la réforme prévaut aussi des mesures
pour faciliter les départs en carrière
longue notamment en prenant en compte et
trimestre de congé parentaux dans la
durée exigée des carrières longues et
que l'âge du taux plein notamment pour
les femmes à carrière hachées doit
restera à 67 ans réduisant ainsi l'écart
qui aujourd'hui pouvaient exister de 5
ans et donc sera réduit de 3 ans ce sont
des mesures j'ai envie de dire qui se
complètent les unes les autres pour
accompagner cette question de la
maternité mais aussi cette question de
l'allongement de la durée de vie et de
la démographie qui qui effectivement
chute tous ces éléments encore une fois
font que le bilan financier de la
réforme est en équilibre en 2030 le
rendement net de la réforme et je tiens
à le redire ici à l'Assemblée nationale
provient à 55 ans des hommes et des
femmes
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Géraldine Grangier merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre
inégalité c'est le seul mot qui me vient
à l'esprit quand je pense à la situation
des femmes au travail inégalité pendant
leurs années travaillées inégalités une
fois en retraite le constat est amer
considère ces dernières persistent pour
celles qui cumulent salaire inférieur et
carrière plus courte et souvent hachée
en chiffres la différence du montant des
pensions de retraite était différente
elle est de 40% en faveur des hommes on
sait que le salaire des femmes sont
quant à eux inférieures à 22% à ceux des
hommes de plus la prise en compte de la
pénibilité au travail cité dans le
projet de loi occulte les métiers
majoritairement féminins certes personne
ne contestera que les métiers du BTP
sont particulièrement pénibles mais si
une raison pour occulter par exemple les
aides-soignantes qui doivent soulever
leur passion
tous les observateurs s'accordent à dire
que la réforme pénalise les femmes
certains vont plus loin en la qualifiant
de sexistes même si la durée de carrière
est en net augmentation nous savons tous
qu'elles restent plus courtes chez les
femmes ceci s'explique notamment par
l'arrivée des enfants nombreux sont
celles qui se retrouvent pénalisées
n'ont pas à cause de leur enfant mais
par leur direction malheureusement
certaines font alors le choix de se
consacrer à l'éducation des enfants et
se mettre pour un certain temps en
retrait de la vie professionnelle
croyez-vous alors que ces entreprises
garderont ces femmes en poste jusqu'à 67
ans croyez-vous vraiment qu’après une
coupure dans leur carrière ces femmes
pourront reprendre un poste équivalent
un salaire équivalent et croyez-vous
sincèrement que ces femmes seront
suffisamment en forme pour travailler
jusqu'à l'aube de leur 70 ans
par ailleurs les femmes sont nettement
majoritaires parmi les aidants à 57%
avec l'augmentation de l'espérance de
vie et du vieillissement de la
population le nombre des aidants va
évoluer à la hausse il faut donc
répondre à cet enjeu sociétal vous avez
annoncé la création d'une assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants afin que les
trimestres consacrés à aider une
personne soit validée pouvez-vous nous
repréciser s'il vous plaît les contours
de sa mise en oeuvre merci madame la
députée madame la ministre merci et
Madame la présidence madame la députée
Grangier au fond la question déjà plus
générale que vous me posez sur la place
des femmes je tiens à dire que cette
réforme ne pénalise pas les femmes au
contraire on va protéger pleinement par
les mesures de notre projet celles qui
ont des carrières hachées qui ont
commencé tôt qui ont de revenus faibles
jusqu'à présent les femmes partaient en
moyenne plus tard que les hommes à la
retraite notamment du fait de leur
interruption de carrière les choses
changent pour les nouvelles générations
de retraités désormais les femmes
partiront légèrement plus tôt que les
hommes de plus de plus en plus souvent
les femmes peuvent conseiller maternité
et poursuite de leur activité et je
crois que cette heureux il y a
aujourd'hui un tiers des trimestres
enfants qui ne sont pas utilisés parce
que les femmes ont pu continuer leur
activité c'est une bonne nouvelle qui
est que nous accompagnerons donc dans
les débats au Sénat sur cette question
des aidants et c'est le sens de
l'article 12 du projet de loi que nous
n'avons pas pu aborder trois grandes
dispositions sont prévues dans le projet
déjà la le fait de créer un dispositif
Haddock pour rassembler finalement
l'ensemble des informations et des
droits épars qui sont souvent mal
connues et finalement source de non
recours au droit le fait également
d'accorder des droits à davantage de
situation des dents notamment à ceux des
parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap bénéficiant du complément d'AEH
et puis enfin de simplifier notamment en
supprimant la condition de cohabitation
avec les dents ou du lien familial
toutes ces dispositions qui viennent
faciliter finalement l'accès aux
dispositions vis-à-vis de l'aidant et
qui au global nous permettront de passer
à plus de 100 000 le nombre de personnes
couvertes contre 70 000 aujourd'hui je
vous remercie
merci
la parole est maintenant pour les
députés non inscrits et les tamanam
Emmanuel Ménard
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le nombre de retraités en
France augmente de 150 000 à 200 000 par
an alors que celui des actifs demeure
relativement stable dans les années 60
on l'a dit le régime général des
salariés comptait plus de 4 cotisants
pour un retraité désormais c'est 1,7 et
ce ratio va continuer à baisser c'est
donc notamment sur ce ratio et sur notre
natalité que nous devons agir pour
permettre à notre système de retraite
par répartition de rester viable dès
lors il est impératif de partir du
principe que les maires de famille
contribuent peut-être plus que tous les
autres à pérenniser nos retraites lors
de la naissance d'un enfant on accorde 8
trimestres dans le privé 4 au titre de
la maternité ou de l'adoption et quatre
titres de l'éducation de l'enfant qui
peuvent depuis 2010 être répartis entre
les deux parents petite précision qui a
son importance ces trimestre compte pour
la durée de cotisation mais pas pour
l'âge de départ avec votre réforme
le décalage de l'âge légal de départ et
fasse donc le bénéfice des trimestres
validés pour la maternité les femmes qui
grâce à ces trimestre pouvait partir de
façon anticipée avec une carrière
complète on estime qu'elles sont plus de
100 000 par an vont désormais devoir
attendre 64 ans parce que vous mélangez
nombre d'annuités et âge de départ parce
qu'il faut travailler jusqu'à 64 ans et
avoir travaillé 43 annuités pour ne pas
subir de décote avec votre projet actuel
les femmes qui ont mis entre parenthèses
leur carrière pour avoir des enfants ou
les élever subissent donc une double
injustice non seulement leur retraite
sont souvent sont souvent moindres du
fait de carrière hachées de salaire
toujours inférieur à ceux des hommes
mais elles seront aussi très souvent
soumises à une décote alors je regrette
que nous n'ayons pas pu avoir le débat
dans l'hémicycle mais pouvez-vous madame
la ministre nous éclairer sur ce que le
gouvernement prendra comme mesure d'une
part pour que le bénéfice des trimestres
raccordés aux femmes pour leur maternité
ne soient pas effacés et d'autre part
pour subissent pas cette décote qu'il
est pénaliserait encore un peu plus je
vous remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Madame la Ministre merci
madame la présidente madame la députée
Ménard concernant les trimestres de
maternité il s'agit probablement d'un
angle de questions sur la surcotte comme
déjà discuté auparavant concernant la
décote des femmes les éléments sont
finalement les mêmes que que ceux pour
la réponse de Madame Bonivard BC l'âge
d'annulation de la décote et
financièrement non réaliste mais le
gouvernement agit pour lutter contre
cette décote avec des trimestres
supplémentaires assimilés pour
l'assurance vieillesse des aidants avec
l'augmentation également de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite qui implique une
décote maximale de 15% plutôt que 25%
pour celles qui souhaitent partir dès
que possible malgré les carrières très
incomplètes je vous remercie
merci alors une dernière question posée
par Madame Fanta Beretta pour le gros
Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues madame la
ministre le ministre Olivier du socle a
indiqué sur BFM TV ce week-end être
d'accord et ouvert à l'enrichissement du
texte des retraites il a notamment
partagé sa volonté de reprendre des
amendements qui lui paraissaient
pertinents mais qui n'avait pas pu être
examiné en commission ou en séance il a
illustré son propos en évoquant un
amendement de notre collègue communiste
visant à corriger la cruelle suppression
de la majoration de pensions pour les
parents de trois enfants lors du décès
de l'un d'eux et nous ne pouvons caler
dans son sens je voudrais pourtant
revenir sur cette majoration pour le
troisième enfant le code de la sécurité
sociale prévoit un montant de 10% pour
la mer et de 10% pour le père savez-vous
que sur les 8,8 milliards d'euros que
coûte cette disposition
5,1 bénéficient à ces messieurs versus
3,7 pour ces dames
c'est en moyenne 140 euros de pension en
plus par mois pour les hommes et
seulement 70 euros pour les femmes c'est
injuste injuste oui parce que ce sont
les femmes qui en fentent ce sont les
femmes dont les carrières sont impactées
par la grossesse et ce sont les femmes
qui touchent les plus petites pensions
pensions moyenne je le rappelle
inférieur de 40 % à celle des hommes le
mode de calcul des majorations pour 3e
enfant réplique donc et accentue les
inégalités femmes hommes accumulées tout
au long de la carrière et c'est une
aberration j'ai déposé un amendement
soutenu par le groupe Renaissance qui
n'a pas pu être examiné lui non plus il
proposait de passer cette majoration de
pensions à 15% pour la mère et à 5% pour
le père ainsi on inverserait le rapport
et c'est 4 millions de femmes qui
verraient leur pension majorée de 800
euros en moyenne par an en plus cette
nouvelle ventilation permettrait même de
dégager selon mes estimations de 100
millions d'euros annuels
si nous nous sommes pas capables de
réparer ce type d'injustice systémique
et hautement symbolique comment
pourrons-nous nous atteler au reste ma
question est donc la suivante que
pensez-vous de cette proposition et
Monsieur le Ministre Olivier du seuf
serait-il prêt à l'apporter comme un
moment Sénat madame la député madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée beurette modifiée la majoration
de de 10% pour famille de trois enfants
ou plus accordée aux deux parents en une
majoration plus importante pour les
femmes que pour les hommes tel est votre
proposition au fond c'est majorations de
10% pour familles nombreuses qui sont
accordés effectivement pour les deux
parents profitent effectivement
davantage en moyenne aux hommes qu'aux
femmes puisque les pensions des hommes
sont aujourd'hui plus élevées que celles
des femmes ce constat il a été fait lors
du projet de réforme du système
universel qui prévoyait de créer des
majorations dès le premier enfant
fléchés vers les femmes et votre
réflexion s'inscrit finalement dans
cette logique nous souhaitons que
celle-ci puisse être abordée dans le
cadre du futur rapport sur les droits
familiaux et conjugaux parce que cette
évolution elle pose de nombreuses
questions plus globales et ce qui est un
consensus pour faire de cette
redistribution des pensions des hommes
vers celles des femmes si oui cette
évolution doit-elle sur les familles
déjà existantes ou seuls sur les enfants
à naître quel mécanismes de partage des
droits entre femmes et hommes mettre en
place et comment prévoir les quatre
séparations faut-il prévoir comme dans
le système universel des majorations dès
le premier enfant et le cas échéant
comment financer cette évolution
finalement il y a énormément de
questions autour de cette proposition et
qu'il reviendra donc à la mission
d'étudier pour rouvrir cette question
sur les droits familiaux et de pouvoir
apporter quelques éléments de réponse je
vous remercie merci madame la ministre
le débat est clos et avant d'entamer le
second débat de l'après-midi je vous
propose une suspension de 10 minutes